[Musique]
non se défend bonsoir ça mais forcément
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
singer view nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement oui bien sûr je suis
ingénieur géologue signé g spécialisée
dans l'évaluation des risques sanitaires
et environnementaux en lien avec les
filière minérale
type d'études gfk diplôme d'ingénieur en
géologie minière et donc ensuite j'ai
travaillé un certain nombre d'années
dans les questions de filière minérale
au sein avant maths sup maths spé
voilà j'ai choisi un parcours assez
assez scientifique s'était pas trop dur
matchbox pays basque avait pas trop de
machisme
barrières et rétrograde c'est beaucoup
mais j'ai vécu une époque je pense que
les choses ont changé aujourd'hui mais
j'ai vécu une époque où notamment la
question de l'abstraction mathématique
c'était pas forcément une faculté qui
était associé en tous les cas dans
l'imaginaire des enseignants aux femmes
donc on en revient aujourd'hui et
heureusement et le la situation de la
femme dans
les compétences scientifiques dans
l'expertisé des choses sur lesquelles on
a encore je pense beaucoup de progrès à
faire
on a décidé de vous faire venir
aujourd'hui parce que
votre travail vos recherches
c'est une de nos principales clés de
lecture je dirais même une clé de voûte
dans notre
capacité à analyser les choses et on est
vraiment très content de pouvoir
discuter avec vous ce soir on va lancer
directement les choses on voulait
commencer par quoi on voulait commencer
parce que si on va peut-être commencer
par les métaux comment les exploitent et
comment les obtient
donc déjà pour commencer il faut avoir
en tête qu'on parle régulièrement de
ressources minières ou de matières
premières minérales de façon à
distinguer
non le monde des matières premières
minérales on distingue deux sondes que
sont d'une part les métaux et les
minéraux industriels c'est important de
les avoir en tête parce que ce soir on
va beaucoup parler des métaux on va
laisser un tout petit peu de côté le
monde et des minéraux industriels
à savoir que quand je parle de minéraux
industriels c'est des choses de votre
quotidien ça peut être des argiles par
exemple qui sont utilisés dans des
crèmes ou dans des pains porte vous
pouvez également trouver le plâtre c'est
du gypse en fait c'est un sulfate de
calcium qui est utilisé pour les plaques
de plâtre voilà ça c'est le monde des
minéraux industriels qui s'exploitent de
s'agit exactement qui s'exploitent en
carrière et d'ailleurs vous avez raison
de l'évoquer puisqu'on va créer un
distinguo dans le droit français
notamment et c'est pas le seul cas entre
les minéraux industriels qui relèvent du
régime carrier et qui donc en fait
relève notamment du code de
l'environnement contrairement aux métaux
un certain nombre de substances en avait
pas que les métaux il y aussi le soufre
il ya aussi la floride notamment qu'ils
vont relever du code minier
donc ouais ça fait un distinguo aussi
notamment dans notre droit on va on va
rentrer dans le détail de tout ça pour
des questions de soutenabilité de nos
fondamentaux de notre société
occidentale
c'est à dire le nerf de la guerre c'est
souvent l'argent mais en fait c'est les
métaux c'est la base de notre
technologie c'est la base de nos
échanges c'est l'électrification des
villes c'est on parle souvent
greenwashing aux bûches bullshit
greenwashing la transition verte la
pseudo transition vers la pseudo
énergies renouvelables et tout ça on
commence par de la mine on commence par
de l'année alors une mine à ciel ouvert
est ce qu'il ya des problèmes
environnementaux ou pas comment on fait
pour stocker les déchets comment on fait
pour exploiter ce truc là le broyage la
concentration des minéraux pour en faire
quoi et en finalité les usages
exactement
donc pour comprendre quels sont les
impacts in fine et décidèrent minérale
il faut se rendre compte et je vais et
jules développé pendant toute cette
intervention c'est que on est sur une
filière un secteur industriel qui est
très différent de toutes les autres
industries il va falloir l'avoir en tête
pour la suite au départ on a souvent des
images d'epinal si je vous dis activités
minières alors certains verront
peut-être les anciens mineurs de charbon
du nord d'autres verront peut-être des
mineurs artisanaux en république
démocratique du congo
on voit surtout un groupement
caterpillar façon dont va te vois la
façon al attar 1 200 tonnes chargement à
450 voilà ce genre de modèle alors en
fait au tout départ on a ces images là
mais il faut revenir je pense au départ
à comment se présente le métal dans le
sous sol
donc un gisement mini déjà je vais
revenir d'ailleurs sur un concept de le
métal est ce qu'il est rare ou pas parce
que il ya tellement de gens qui qui
explique en fait la rareté des métaux
ils disent ah oui nous savez il ya des
métaux rares qui va falloir exploiter et
c est une espèce de mythologie autour de
la rareté du métal métal est rare il ya
cinq métaux qui font exception que sont
en l'occurrence le fer le manganèse
l'aluminium le titane ont peu importe le
cinquième essai langres où les 5 et les
quatre majeurs et à part ces métaux la
majorité des métaux dans les gisements
on va les trouver à des concentrations
qui sont plutôt de l'ordre du pur sang
ou du dixième de pour cent voire encore
moins on sera grammes par tonne vous
vraiment s'imaginer que les
concentrations dans les gisements je
prends l'exemple par exemple du prenons
l'exemple du tungstène on est entre 0 2
et 3%
entre 0 2 et 3% prenons l'exemple par
exemple de l'uranium on est entre 0,1 et
0,3 pour cent sélections d'exploitation
voilà exactement à lattes donc c'est un
pourcentage donc effectivement bas à la
tonne ça vous donne un ordre de grandeur
vous pouvez aussi avoir par exemple
tient le lithium dont on parle beaucoup
dans les salles art aujourd'hui sur les
toners d'exploitation moyenne dans les
salaires en autour de 0 05 à 0 15%
et ça c'est des métaux on va dire
classique ensuite si on se dirige vers
le monde des métaux précieux l'or
l'argent le platine on sera plutôt dans
l'ordre de l'ordre du gramme par tonne
la moyenne des 400 gisements exploités
en 2015 on était à un point 15 grammes
par tonne
sur l'argent on est entre quelques
dizaines quelques centaines de grammes
par tonne le platine ces quelques
grammes par tonne pour quelle
consommation énergétique au niveau de la
place jasmin alors au niveau de la
consommation énergétique ça va vraiment
dépendre de la méthode d'exploitation et
la méthode de traitement vous êtes assez
dépendant de ça donc c'est pour ça on en
parlera justement après par rapport à ça
mais ça va vraiment dépendre sachant que
le gros poste de énergétique bas on
verra il n'est pas là où on pense qu'il
est donc voilà donc il va falloir aller
chercher des toners extrêmement faible
et le deuxième enjeu c'est que non
seulement va chercher des toners faible
mais on a aussi une image d'epinal en
temps dans une mine de cuivre du cuivre
et de la roche mais absolument pas en
fait absolument pas une mine de cuivre
c'est aussi probablement de l'arsenic ça
peut être un certain nombre d'éléments
souvent du molybdène d'ailleurs il est
très fréquent que les mines de cuivre et
comme co produit sert qu'ils produisent
également du molybdène par exemple
prenons le cas de l'or dont on parle peu
finalement mais pourtant il faudrait
peut-être en parler davantage si on
prend le cas de l'or il ya une vie
substances qui sont régulièrement
associés notamment celles qu'on connaît
assez souvent qui associée alors c'est
l'argent
qui est un gros coproduit des mines d'or
qui est très rare de trouver une mine
d'or qui ne contiennent pas d'argent
mais vous avez aussi tout un ensemble de
substances métalliques donc en
particulier ceux qu'on connaît assez
facilement le cuivre le zinc sa session
ce qu'on retrouve régulièrement
l'antimoine l'uranium c'est des
coproduits fréquent des mines d'or mais
il ya également très souvent associée du
mercure de l'arsenic et du baryum halde
et honneur qui peuvent être très
importantes peut-être que certains de
certains d'entre vous connaissent la
mine de salsigne qui se trouvent dans
l'aude à côté de carcassonne elle a été
la plus grande mine d'or en france
métropolitaine cette mine est plus
longtemps le premier producteur mondial
d'arsenic et pas seulement la première
mine d'or en france donc si on sait à
part ce moment c'est que dans un
gisement on a une substance mais tout un
cortège
autre substance on se doute que si on
veut récupérer par exemple que le cuivre
ou que leur nom va dé facto soit à
récupérer un petit peu des autres métaux
soit on va tout jeter
donc si on se projette par rapport aux
chiffres que j'ai annoncée précédemment
si on prend le cas ding d'or mais le
raisonnement est valable pour les autres
métaux j'ai un gramme par tonne un
gramme d'or par tonne de roche donc il
faut que j'extrais une tonne de roche
que je la traite pour obtenir un gramme
d'or et bien se dire que dans la tonne
que j'ai rejeté finalement et bien je
vais retrouver en un cortège métallique
conséquent et dans ces métaux il ya un
certain nombre de substances métalliques
ou métalloïdes qui sont particulièrement
dangereuses pour la santé humaine ou
pour l'environnement et une fois qu'on a
compris ça et qu'on voit les chiffres de
production je parle de chiffres actuels
je parle pas encore des prévisions on
comprend assez naturellement qu'on va
devoir dealé avec des quantités
phénoménales
de déchets miniers
et qui contiennent aléatoirement de
l'arsenic du plomb ou autre alors toutes
les mines ne sont pas les mêmes elles
n'ont pas toutes le même cortège
métallique qui leur est attribué ou
associés et pour autant et bien ça c'est
le mal de l'industrie minérale c'est le
fait que ce soit un des plus gros je
dirais générateur du secteur industriel
qui génère le plus de contaminants et
surtout de contaminants métalliques je
vous coupe bien soit je pense que ces
bonnes âmes
chargée d'exploiter nos mines ou quand
même des mesures proactives pour éviter
de contaminer le biotope doit ya
forcément avoir du traitement de l'eau
des traitement des boues du stockage
comment ça se passe vous avez un deux
trois mots pour nous expliquer les
mesures proactives de l'industrie
minière alors les mesures proactives de
l'industrie minière
il faut avoir conscience des limites de
notre capacité à mettre en place des
mesures proactives
quand vous exploitez en souterrain que
vous soyez avec une mine en ciel ouvert
vous savez comme se forme d'escargot là
où que vous soyez en souterraines des
puits des galeries vous allez rencontrer
l'eau vous allez rencontrer des grandes
quantités de seaux d'eau souterraine
saison il va falloir les pompes et
vous pouvez mettre en place des mesures
proactives pour récupérer les eaux les
traités et cetera mais à terme vous
serez quand même limité vous êtes face à
face avec quasiment des forces
telluriques si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
quoi on parle de millions de litres
d'eau qui sont pompés chaque année sur
beaucoup de sites miniers industriels du
tout alors en général allaient soit au
mieux traitée puis rocher dans
l'environnement soit rejetée dans
l'environnement
donc voilà ça c'est un exemple ensuite
vous avez la question des déchets on
parle assez régulièrement de masse de
déchets générés qui sont autour de
millions d ordre de grandeur de millions
de dizaines de millions de centaines de
millions ça cédé à main qu'il faut
stocker alors on peut effectivement
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mesures mais on est naturellement
contraint par la grandeur des objets qui
sont présents donc je dirais que avant
de parler des mesures qui permettent de
limiter les effets il faut avoir en tête
la dimension des objets et des échelles
au quotidien quand on parle de la mine
industrielle on parle des chaînes qui
sont kilométrique ou purée kilométrique
je vais vous donner un exemple si je
prends cet exemple de l'eau l'admin
classe économique est une mine d'or
uranium cuivre en australie qui
s'appelle olympique dames cette mine
elle pompe les on allait en souterrain
auquel pompe les aubert en gros pour que
les mineurs puissent travailler dans de
bonnes conditions car ça en noyer cette
mine elle pompe un certain nombre de
litres peu importe le volume par contre
peut vous donner les effets à long terme
on se rend compte
cette mine se trouve au dessus de ce
qu'on appelle le graet à un seizième
bassine qui en fait une grande grande
nappe très profondes qui se trouvait en
australie
c'est la plus grosse profonde et la plus
importante nappe artésienne au monde ce
pas n'importe quel aquifères
à 2 à l'horizon 2050 5 donc au terme de
ce qu'on ne pense être la fin de
l'activité minière on pense que le
niveau d'eau souterrains dans ce bassin
qui se trouvent autour de cette mine
aura diminué de 10 mètres sur
4400 km carrés
alors on va pouvoir effectivement
envisager un certain nombre de mesures
on peut se dire marc écouter on va
attendre d'après une fois qu'on a pompé
on va arrêter de compter non mon horaire
était de combler les fluides vont
revenir à l'équilibré et cetera c'est
des choses qu'on peut tout à fait
entendre et on parle quand même d'une
diminution de 10 mètres sur 4400 km car
quand on parle de stockage des déchets
on pourra rentrer si vous le souhaitez
dans comment on traite et puis comment
on va récupérer ledit métal mais bon on
a on se dit voilà on part avec un
certain nombre de millions de tonnes de
roches à traiter par an et on va se
retrouver que des déchets qui se trouve
le plus souvent sous forme de bouard
soit sous forme de gravats si on parle
de stériles miniers sous forme de boues
si on parle de résidus liés peu importe
on fait un stockage de 200 allez on va
dire aller entre elle-même 50 millions
de tonnes pourquoi pas un stockage
moyens comment aujourd'hui il faut
stocker déjà 50 millions on n'a pas du
tout
on n'a pas de méga poubelle puis comme
c'est sous forme de boules souvent les
montagnes on a du mal on arrive à le
faire avec certains résident yeux comme
les terrils parce que on a un peu
d'humidité donc c'est cohérent fins et
on a une certaine compétence du matériau
donc on peut en faire effectivement
comme un tas de sable mais quand on est
avec des boues qui sont plutôt liquide
c'est compliqué il faut trouver une
baignoire à remplir
alors il ya différentes techniques qui
existent
pour les stocker la première qui est la
plus connue c'est le rappel le parc à
résidus ou la digue à résidus non
principe était assez simple il va
falloir créer un barrage sur le principe
c'est le même chose qu'un barrage
hydroélectrique sauf qu'à la place de
l'eau on met des déchets miniers sous
forme de boues et puis en fait on va
créer ce barrage et puis on va mettre
les bouts au fur et à mesure derrière
il ya une autre technique qui existe
alors on pourrait largement parlé des
limites parce que quand vous avez des
dépôts de ce type qui vous représentez d
échelle de 100 200 500 mille hectares
voire plus
rio tinto peut-être qu'il ya des gens
qui connaissent et me casser connu mine
de cuivre-or en espagne l'air de
traitement des déchets c'est 500
hectares alors j'essaye de continuer à
répondre à votre question en me disant
va falloir réhabiliter ou gérer 500
hectares
500 hectares quand même quand
quelques dizaines de mètres voilà donc
après ça peut être très très haut ça
dépend de la morphologie vous perdez dit
qu'il monte à 300 mètres voire plus haut
que la tour 1 du coup le tour eiffel ou
plus haut que la tour eiffel
donc effectivement
il ya donc il ya cette première
technique c'est le déversement endiguée
vous avez une deuxième technique qui
existe qui est de plus en plus mise en
oeuvre c'est la réintroduction des
résidus dans les vides créés par
l'exploitation du trou en bouche le trou
alors on peut pas boucher le trou à 100%
puisque dans le trou avant qu'un trou
vous avez pris de la roche qui était
très intégrée qui était très compétente
vous l'avez sorti vous l'avez broyés
dans très très faim vous l'avez vous
avez ajouté de l'eau vous à gage était
de l'air donc le volume que prend ce
matériau même si la même masque au
départ là de fait il est bien supérieur
donc en général on peut pas toujours
tout réintroduire d'après un document de
la commission européenne sur ces
questions on estimait que les meilleurs
mines européenne aujourd'hui en termes
de réintroduction de résidus on était
sûr maximum 52 % ça vous donne un peu un
ordre de grandeur ce n'est pas la
solution non plus mais ça peut aider par
après on pourra aussi détailler toutes
les méthodes qui existent dans ce
domaine certaines étant catastrophique
et puis ensuite ya une troisième méthode
auquel il fallait penser qu'il n'y avait
pensé dès le départ c'est l'utiliser
c'est vous prenez le clio et vous le
mettez dans la merde dans la rivière
c'est encore le plus pratique le bouchon
c'est surtout moins cher alors
économiquement c'est très compétitif on
pensait à six textes que c'était
alors si ce texte est l'association dont
je fais parti que je représente
aujourd'hui donc si ce texte est pour un
système extractif et environnement c'est
une association qui est né en 2009 qui
est principalement composé de personnes
du secteur ou proches du secteur donc ça
peut être d un des ingénieurs miniers
des chercheurs également des géographes
des hydrogéologues
et cette association une association
solidarité internationale qui a pour but
de de deux choses
sensibiliser et apporter de la
connaissance et de l'information
dans la sphère publique pour qui un
véritable débat sur les questions
minérale et une réappropriation par tous
de ces questions c'est le premier enjeu
est le deuxième un jeu c'est d'être en
capacité d'utiliser nos connaissances
nous savoir nos expériences en tant de
professionnels du milieu ou pas
d'ailleurs parfois proche du milieu ou
en temps professionnel pour pouvoir
aider la société civile qui est en
difficulté ou qui a besoin d'eux réponse
simple à ces questions lorsqu'elle est
confrontée à des projets miniers ou à
des
questions minières ça peut aller
jusqu'au bout des filières miracle vous
avez des conflits d'intérêts qu'est-ce
qui vous finance
alors deux grandes fondations la
fondation charles léopold meilleur pour
le progrès de l'homme et une autre
fondation qui s'appelle la fondation un
monde par tous ça représente 75% de nos
financements et ce sont deux fondations
familiales privées à but philanthropique
qui sont sous l'égide de la fondation de
france et donc les 25 % quand ce sont
des adhésions des dons est aussi une
partie des activités commerciales qu'on
peut mener quand on intervient par
exemple sur deûle expertise ou des
études comme on l'a réalisé par exemple
pour des collectivités ou autre ou là on
pourrait être rémunéré un petit peu sur
cette activité là désolé pour cette
petite aparté avec les donc là on a vu
que
moi il y avait des petites solutions
pour
filtrer ce taux qui est ce qu'il ya eu
des catastrophes
par exemple en barrage de boue qui
s'ouvre sur une vallée est ce qu'il ya
eu par exemple des déversement de boues
rouges quelque part est ce que par
exemple il ya eu des enfants qui ont des
petits boutons des démos renée des
moignons auprès des nouveaux nés
des petites choses comme ça
alors il est vrai que les stockages dit
andy lit donc les fameux parc à résidus
sont régulièrement soumis à des
problèmes donc c'est ce grand stockage
là on pense en fonction des années qu'on
est entre quatre à six accidents majeurs
parents à l'international c'est en
moyenne sachant que les statistiques
dont on dispose sont partiel puisqu'il
arrive qu'il y ait des accidents de plus
petite ampleur qui ne soit pas
nécessairement référencé dans les bases
de données auxquelles on a accès on va
dire en tant que grand public plutôt
chaud
ça fait un peu tache ou alors les grands
de rupture de barrage qui ont eu lieu
nous on en a pas beaucoup entendu parler
pourtant en europe on en a vécu des très
importantes
1998 c'est une rupture de digue à
arsenal collard à côté de séville en
espagne c'est 7 millions de mètres cubes
de résidus sulfuré qui se sont déversées
donc en sortie voyez comme je le disais
un barrage pour vous imaginez ça peut
faire une coulée de boue c'est un
équivalent d'une coulée sas et
régionales couleurs 1998 deux ans après
seulement 2000 c'est la roumanie c'est
une catastrophe sur une digue à baia
mare est une mine d'or
quatre mois après trois quatre mois
après bye ammar et c'est à quelques
kilomètres de là toujours un roumanie
une deuxième rupture de digue la mine de
plomb zinc de borsa
et huit ans après c'est la hongrie avec
koh lanta rck est une enseigne d'allumer
timing pardon d'aluminium
là en l'occurrence voyez ça c'est
1998-2002 épisode 2008 c'est très très
gros événement
il faut s'imaginer que on va libérer
massivement et brutalement des volumes
qui en général pour les cas majeurs on
est souvent sur des heures de grandeur
du million de mètres cubes de boue qui
vont être largué instantanément
récemment on a eu des épisodes qu'on
connaît un 2015 au brésil
dans la zone de benneteau rodrigues un
petit village c'est là la zone devant la
mine de san marco on a eu une coulée de
boue qui a qui a rejoint un fleuve qui
s'appelle le rio doce qui est lui même
c'est juste du coup dans l'océan
atlantique 500 plus de 500 km parcourus
par les résidus benneteau rodrigues il
ya dix-neuf personnes qui sont mortes
sous la coulée de boue est beaucoup plus
récemment peut-être que vous en avez
entendu parler c'est la mine de brimades
ignaux toujours au brésil là cette fois
ci c'est c'est vraiment à quatre ans
d'intervalle c'est toujours sur des
mines de fer dans les deux cas c'est des
mines de fer se noue l'exploitant
champion ou pas alors dans le sait le
même exploitant partiellement c'est à
dire que dans un cas il est
seul exploitant qui dans un autre caïd
en association avec un autre
mais je vous dirai en fait que peu
importe l'exploitant tous les gens dont
je parle enfin tous les cas dont je
parle sont des exploitants différent il
ya bien un point commun ce sont les
ruptures pendant très longtemps quand on
a faim c'est une rupture de digue
dramatique a eu lieu en 2014 personnes
en a entendu parler - de pollet au
canada c'est du cuivre un peu on a eu
encore plusieurs millions de mètres
cubes en plus on est dans une zone avec
des sexes et des zones de lacq donc
enfin des coulées de boue de cette
ampleur là dans des environnements de
forêt de l'axé c'est ingérable sait on
peut prendre ou pas le traité voyez
c'est très très compliqué à
réparer ou à nettoyer dont la demie nous
avait dit non non ok ok 2017 le
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement s'empare de la question
il rédige un rapport qui est assez
connue qui s'appelle cestino accident
dans lequel il dit écoutez là il ya un
problème avec les ruptures de digues il
explique le pr nations unies explique
que c'est systématiquement des
problématiques de négligence de
sous-estimation que en fait on peut
intervenir en fait c'est qu'on n'est pas
assez de moyens pour entretenir ses
ouvrages pour des raisons économiques
pour des principalement pour des raisons
économiques en même temps ça s'entend on
parle de déchets donc le moins d'argent
dans un modèle économique peut-on mettre
sur un déchet le mieux on se porte son
temps
vous nous avez dit voilà le plus tape le
poing sur la table il ya un gros rapport
très très belle étude qui a été faite en
2017 2019 ça recommence donc à brommat
dinho comme je disais tout à l'heure
cette fois ci on a 300 personnes mortes
et disparus parce qu'il s'avère que la
cantine et laboratoires et d'autres
ateliers se trouve en aval immédiat de
cette dig dig fermé des qui a été fermée
c'est à dire c'est une c'est un dépôt de
résidus qui a été refermé par un apport
de végétaux apparu n'apporte de terre et
puis digitalisation
alors pour faire propre oui mais en fait
on considère que l a fini son travail il
a dit qu elle a plus besoin d'accueillir
des résidus donc on la ferme
donc effectivement vous avez raison
d'insister sur ce sujet parce que la
question des résidus miniers de leur
stockage et des catastrophes liées aux
digues mien c'est un problème qui est
certainement l'une des problématiques
environnementales déjà de gestion pour
l'exploitant et ensuite environnemental
pendant la période d'exploitation et sur
le long terme qui est majeure majeur le
résidus miniers dans la mine le déchets
miniers fin c'est le sait vraiment mais
le mont noir quoi de la mine passé il
faut s'imaginer que c'est ingérable en
fait et c'est le plus gros volume avec
lequel on va travailler au regard des
toners que je présentais précédemment
quand vous avez un gisement de cuivre
2010cette moyenne des gisements de
cuivre du chili stoner 0 67% ça a
diminué de 2,2 effectivement une
trentaine d'années 0 61% de mémoire et 0
61%
c'est à dire que vous allez jeter 99 et
des poussières pour cent peu importe le
39 on s'en fiche 99 % des déchets de
faute de votre la masque vous allez
travailler transporte et traités c'est
du déchet je peux faire l'avocat du
diable mais ma petite dame vous rendez
pas compte on fait marcher l'économie
mondiale ou la porte le progrès
comment au frais pour faire des petites
éoliennes et planter des panneaux
solaires un peu partout si vous n'avez
pas nos propres mines qu'est ce que
c'est que ce travail fait normal qu'on
fasse des déchets pour faire de
l'économie verte alors la question des
usages en on va en reparler long si vous
voulez je fais je le fais exprès
on va en reparler longuement parce
qu'effectivement
la raison pour laquelle moi je vous en
parle en ces termes pour que justement
on n'entende pas ça et je vais y
affirmer c'est que l'industrie minière
c'est le plus gros générateurs de
déchets solides liquides et gazeux parmi
toutes les autres secteurs industriels
on sait que c'est mon ordinateur
[Rires]
c'est ça c'est le plus gros seins si
vous voulez je possède je vais j'ai bien
entendu votre question sur les visages
mais c'est justement pour répondre à ça
en fait c'est de dire certes en fait il
ya un besoin de métaux et souvent ce
qu'on entend alors c'est un peu dans la
lignée de ce que vous venez de dire
c'est oui mais en même temps toutes les
industries ont des impacts donc c'est
normal quand on veut quelque chose
demain se donner la peine et puis à
toutes les industries des impacts
l'industrie minière n'a rien à voir avec
les autres industries elle est
extrêmement différente pour les raisons
de fonctionnement que je mentionnais
pour des raisons de taille mais aussi au
regard en fait de si vous voulez de son
emprise sur elle à des emprises spatiale
extrêmement importante alors pareil hein
j'ouvre une parenthèse mais comme ça
c'est dit la majorité des mines du monde
sont exploitées en ciel ouvert et sont à
grande échelle
donc souvent on a tendance à nous
opposer un homme il faut pas caricaturer
toutes les mines sont pas gigantesques
alors toutes les mines ne sont pas
gigantesques cette phrase est vrai la
majorité du mines du monde 57 % des
mines du nombre de sites miniers du
monde sont à ciel ouvert ça représente
88 % de la production de métaux la mine
industrielle c'est 90% des métaux 60%
des minéraux industriels et 80% du
charbon c'est ça la mine industrielle
donc effectivement je vais plutôt et
assistex on va plutôt parler de cette
mine lin parce que c'est elle qui porte
le gros de la production minière où la
production primaire de notre économie et
donc de notre économie tout à fait donc
aux personnes qui rétorquent que ça il
faut vraiment avoir en tête le fait de
dire teint il faut pouvoir tout de suite
se rendre compte en disant ok très bien
un développement économique et
industriel requiert un certain nombre
d'adaptations d'activité je peux tout à
fait l'entendre on revient absolument
pas sur ce fait c'est l'échelle des
impacts par rapport à la production et à
sang qu'est ce qu'on en pense qu'on en
fait en fait et vous allez voir
l'échelle des intacte
illustration
le plus gros la plus grande mine à ciel
ouvert d'afrique du sud elle s'appelle
palabora c'est un mine à ciel ouvert qui
fait deux kilomètres de diamètre sur 700
62 mètres de haut 762 m de haut ces
trois tours eiffel fin de tour eiffel
ennemis quoi on s'entend c'est vraiment
énorme
cette mine en fait on a travaillé avec
un a pris attache avec un photographe
qui tente de représenter la production
métallique finale d'un site minier sous
forme de boules au droit du site minier
en termes d'illustration on a pris cette
boule à partir de ce travail de ce
photographe donc la production de cuivre
en l'occurrence c'est comme si le
photographe dillon marshall
et on a fait l'exercice et ensuite on
est allé sur google earth on a regardé
l'emprise des installations de surface
et des dépôts miniers ça faisait 25 km²
et au delà de ces 25 kilomètres carrés
1000e point de cette boule vous allez me
dire bah oui mais vous compare une boule
avec une surface oui je sais mais enfin
un moment fort présenter les choses vous
avez pour vous présenter ohlala vous
avez cette emprise qui est là et vous
avez un petit point la sas et le métal
philippe une pure voilà exactement sous
forme de cathodes quoi finale produit
final produit marchand donc en fait ce
ce sur quoi je souhaite et au nom de six
textes insisté c'est de dire quel est le
rapport entre le bénéfice qu'on en tire
que ce soit individuellement
collectivement et les externalités ou
les conséquences que ça il faut
expliquer que ce père dodu à d'autres
communautés d'accord c'est cause
d'externalités sur une exploitation
minière et en fait c'est une conséquence
indésirable ou conséquence désirable ya
des externalités positives par exemple
vous allez insuffler
vous à les embaucher des gens donc vous
allez leur reverser des des salaires du
coût externalités positives vous
contribuez au développement économique
externalités négatives vous émettez
massivement de l'arsenic dans les eaux
voilà donc vous avez un peu c'est les
deux c'est cette notion donc pourquoi je
vois là je parle de la question des
externalités parce que il ya deux ans je
pour nous dans la conception de savoir
quelles activités minières on veut pour
quelle production derrière c'est déjà de
se dire un l'activité minière là j'ai
donné que le cas de l'environnement mais
on peut développer les questions
sociales et les questions humaines on
n'est pas en reste un sourcil ou peu de
bande
et ensuite
et se peser sa donc prendre tout ça les
fameuses externalités aussi négative non
je faisais et dont je parlais et ensuite
le bénéfice qu'on en tire et à quoi ça
sert et je discutais dernièrement avec
un membre de six textes qui me disait tu
sais ce qui me fait le plus de mal
c'est de voir en fait ce qu'on en fait
du métal à la fin surtout ce que ça a
demandé et de me rendre compte à la fin
de ce qu'on en fait et c'est tellement
injuste c'est tellement inadapté c'est
même tellement grotesque en fait vous
rendez pas compte celle fille avec une
bouche de canard
prix avec un téléphone machin 12 ça n'a
pas de prix je ne m'en rends pas compte
bien faire des trous dans le sol pour
faire des seule fille avec une bouche
championnat alors c'est est ce que ça
fait deux fois que vous me posez la
question on va prendre le cas de la
problématique des usages on reviendra
sur la question des impacts la question
des usages
vous avez parlé du sel fille parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui on met
énormément en avant la question du
numérique dont principalement souvent
même quand on parle du mékong restreint
beaucoup le débat aux téléphones
portables aux ordinateurs portables en
fait c'est beaucoup plus large en fait
c'est tout le les appareils numériques
ce qu'on n'a pas dit mal dit que dis je
ne sais pas
on verra ce qu'on mettra comme objectif
après comme pardon adverbe de
cigarettes tout était comme un téléphone
tout notre quotidien en fait nos tout le
monde il est matériellement fondée sur
le métal
et sa m1 ça date pas de l'innovation de
l'apparition des selles fille quoi
malheureusement ça date d'il ya
plusieurs siècles et ç'a toujours été le
cas c'est à dire que l'interaction
modèle de développement et mines enfin
industrie indépendamment du modèle de
développement pour l'instant industrie
mines c'est extrêmement liés et
d'ailleurs c'est lié et je reprends une
terminologie que j'aime beaucoup de
christmann d'une publication qui l'a
fait en 2020 c'est elles sont liées par
des boucles complexe de rétroaction et
j'aime beaucoup cette idée c'est à dire
qu'en fait on a souvent on voit une
image d'épinal indien bombe à
l'industrie elle a besoin de plus on l
appelle la mine bonjour j'ai besoin de
plomb âgées vous cherchez du plomb alors
qu'en fait c'est beaucoup plus complexe
en fait c'est que vous avez des moments
où l'industrie minière les produits
produits produit quelque chose et on
sait pas trop quoi faire de son produit
on va trouver le moyen dans l'industrie
bad de convenir en fin de d'utiliser la
dite matière ladite substance je vais
vous donner un exemple par exemple sur
cet usage là à la fin du 19e siècle
pendant très longtemps on a exploité des
gisements de pyrite pour faire de
l'acide sulfurique pour l'industrie
chimique
à la fin du 19e siècle et des nouveaux
procédés notamment chloration et
procédés de solvay qui font qu'on a
moins besoin d'acide sulfurique
dans l'industrie chimique et donc on a
des mines de pyrite notamment dans le
rhône en a une qui est très connu en
france métropolitaine où on a on a une
mine de cléon produit de la pyrite on
peut laisser sulfurique que va-t-on en
faire eh ben on a trouvé un débouché à
les engrais prenez du phosphate mettait
de l'acide sulfurique dessus vous faites
du super phosphate simple c'est un
engrais phosphatés
et alors que du coup les industriels de
l'époque fin 19e début 20e commencent à
s'inquiéter de leur production
donc d'abord de fabrication pyrite
pardon j'ai pas précisé la pyrite et un
sulfure de fer pour la production
d'acide sulfurique on a dit pas c'est
bon on a trouvé autre cas dans les
années 75 pas si vous vous souvenez il y
avait eu des scandales par rapport à des
collèges des établissements qui a dont
la charpente dans la structure était
faite à base d'acier il ya vu un certain
nombre de problèmes avec des
établissements qui étaient pas aux
normes notamment par rapport au risque
incendie et autres
exactement mais ces genres de choses et
je sais pas s'il y avait eu un certain
nombre de problèmes et c'était aussi
valable en grande bretagne il y avait
aussi des les mêmes problèmes notamment
c'était surtout preuve de résistance au
feu de mémoire j'ai lu des publications
pour la grande bretagne de gens qui ont
étudié les phénomènes historiques et
dans les témoignages des gens que vous
retrouviez des gens qui ont témoigné en
dire mais pourquoi est ce que vous avez
fait appel ce type de structure mais les
gens vous disais ah oui mais en même
temps on était à une époque où
l'industrie de l'acier c'était durant
donc ces exemples-là vous montre à quel
point les deux sont liés et les deux
sont liés dans notre quotidien tout le
temps elles sont liés historiquement
la machine à vapeur la première fois
qu'on a utilisé une machine à vapeur
c'était pour pomper l'eau dans les
gisements de charbon qui était trop
profond c'est la machine à vapeur elle
est liée au fait qu'on voulait exploiter
plus de mines afin plus profondément une
mine de charbon la première la première
ligne de chemin de fer qu'on a créé ses
la ligne saint etienne andrézieux 1827
de mémoire passe une ligne de chemin de
fer pour transporter du charbon vous
voyez que les innovations technologiques
l'industrie et la mine tout ça c'est
très très lié centrales nucléaires radio
radio pas pour faire des tice pour faire
une bombe les centrales nucléaires et
l'uranium l'informatique et les petits
métaux fins vous pouvez puis après vous
pouvez plus ou moins associée à ce qu'on
appelle les révolutions industrielles ou
pas d'ailleurs mais ça a été toujours le
cas et aujourd'hui bah c'est valable
dans le transport il faut d'ailleurs pas
comme commence à parler de transport
donc avant de parler de la véhicules
électriques il y aura déjà le véhicule
car ni qui a plein de métaux à
l'intérieur la mobylette la trottinette
et puis après vous aurez le train
l'avion le bateau on n'en parle même pas
le ferry s'il faut bon les transports
vous avez les technologies de
l'information et de la communication
dont on est de plus en plus proche donc
on sera peut-être un petit peu plus
compte et encore du contenu métallique
de ces appareils et puis ensuite vous
allez avoir les infrastructures
l'électrification le bâtiment
jusqu'à l'agroalimentaire c'est à dire
que je disais tout à l'heure quand on
fait quand on fait quand on met acide
sulfurique plus
faux soit ben ça fait super phosphate
simple si vous remettez de l'acide
phosphorique de si vous faites un super
ce fauteuil phosphate triple pardon bon
peu importe vous avez ça dans
l'agriculture pour les engrais vous
l'avez aussi par exemple les hawks
hydroxyde il ya un scandale il ya
quelques années d oxyde d'aluminium qui
était utilisé en certaines pâtisseries
industrielles la cosmétique dans la
cosmétique vous avez énormément de
matières premières minérales
les gobelets en plastique les mois je me
souviens je m'étais posé la question de
savoir comment c'était assez naïf gt gt
petit me disais mais comment est-ce
qu'on peut mettre une chaise en
plastique au soleil qu'elle ne fondent
pas en faisant des études dans ces
domaines à j'ai compris en fait qu'ils
avaient des dopages à des matières
premières minérales qui évitait que ça
fonde
donc à la cosmétique et c'est partout en
fait ce que nous on voit comme tendance
c'est que s'il ya une sur minéralisation
rampante une sur minéralisation est sûre
métallisation tu sais on peut choisir le
terme que l'on souhaite de notre
quotidien
alors au départ on est on a eu voilà les
transports puis les infrastructures puis
de plus en plus donc regarder votre
quotidien on peut regarder dans notre
quotidien à savoir je sais pas
l'électroménager les peintures ont parlé
tout à l'heure du plâtre ensuite vous
pouvez prendre le numérique n'en parlons
même pas longtemps cette voiture et
notre trip en faut car faut qu'avec
l'extraire il faut quand même faire
quelque chose c'est mais c'est une
carrière de gypse c'est ça n'a pas le
même effet mais par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que vous
mettez beaucoup beaucoup de minéraux
nous ce qui nous intéresse à six textes
sincèrement la question des carrières
pour nous n'est pas prioritaire les
carrières vous l'avoir en tête termes
d'impact c'est beaucoup moins important
c'est pour plein de raisons des raisons
géologiques des raisons giteau le
lendemain des raisons de gisements il ya
effectivement oui effectivement on peut
avoir des grosses carrière avec des
emprises avec des envols de poussières
etc mais je vais après fermer la
parenthèse sur les carrières il ya deux
phénomènes secure est déjà
géologiquement egitto logiquement certes
en termes de jugement c'est pas du tout
la même chose une mine métallique qu'une
carrière de gypse on va commencer par là
ensuite c'est pas du tout les mêmes
tonnage dire qu'en fait vous avez un
meilleur ratio vous n'êtes pas un pour
cent de gypse de quoi vous êtes
peut-être à 1 % de cuivre mais vous
n'êtes pas important de gypse donc vous
avez moins de traitements vous avez
moins de transport etc etc puis un
aspect important qui rejoint ce que je
disais en introduction c'est que c'est
en france et c'est valable dans d'autres
pays mais en france les carrières
relèvent du code de l'environnement la
mine n'en relève pas elles relèvent du
code minier
les règles environnementales
dans les deux cas ne sont pas les mêmes
il ya un régime d'exception au niveau du
code minier on pourra revenir dessus si
c'est nécessaire donc ce qui fait que
une fois que une fois qu'on a compris ça
effectivement ça que je vous explique
tout ça pour vous dire qu'effectivement
nous à 6 sec sont travaillent beaucoup
moins sur les carrières ont trahi
exclusivement sur les mines pour ces
raisons là et pour principalement pour
ces raisons là donc vous avez une sur
minéralisation est donc en fait comme je
disais on aujourd'hui on a l'impression
de découvrir parce que on nous parle
beaucoup
et on pourra développer ça vous
intéresse on va aussi développer ça
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
nous reparle de la mine alors que
pendant des années on s'est bien gardé
de le faire c'est quand même assez
intéressant qu'aujourd'hui le sujet
revienne n'en parlait plus parce que
c'était chez les pauvres qu'on faisait
des trous c'est pas vraiment maintenant
non mais non
oui et non c'est à dire que
effectivement à partir
des années 80 progressivement on a fermé
de plus en plus de mines fermeture de
salsigne la mine d'or dont je parlais
tout à l'heure c'est 2004 de mémoire
c'est à peu près la même date que le
puits de charbon de la houve dans l'est
de la france c'est à peu près la même
période des bassins uranifère dans
limousin du côté de décines ça donne à
peu près c'est les années 2001 on parle
pas des années 75 déjà quand même ce pas
si loin de ça il ya effectivement
quelques rares sites miniers qui
subsistent sur le territoire
métropolitain aujourd'hui quelques mines
de bauxite pour l'aluminium et puis
quelques mines de sel qui celles qui
relèvent du code minier
donc voilà notamment une mine qui est
très connue avant ranger ville pas très
loin de nancy
allons donc effectivement on a commencé
à tous fermés à partir des années 80 on
avait de moins en moins de sites qui
étaient en exploitation aujourd'hui on
en a très peu mais il y en avait partout
à côté
la roumanie l'espagne la grande bretagne
l'allemagne la pologne les états unis le
canada j'ai pas besoin d'aller ni en
amérique latine ni en afrique ni en
birmanie pour vous trouver des noms
dominent qui n'ont pas cessé de
fonctionner activement pendant le moment
où l'on faisait notre hibernation
cérébrale sur les questions minières
donc séminal continué massimo la mine
une mine dont on pourrait largement par
les quais la mine de rosia pollinique
est la plus grande mine de cuivre
d'europe elle a commencé dans les années
80 de mémoire enfin certainement même
avant elle a toujours fonctionné avec
six textes on l'a visitée en 2017 elle
se porte comme un charme c'est pour bien
je joue vraie parenthèse
vous avez une expérience de terrain vous
avez été voir tout plein de choses un
peu partout les conditions de travail
des gens est-ce que vous pouvez juste
nous parler de votre expérience de
terrain pour bien remettre l'église au
centre du village heures
j'ai l'impression en fait que quand vous
êtes une femme ou vos propos sérieux
s'arrêter en général ce qui se passe les
cours spécialement dans le domaine
minier l'eau oui j'étais fier donc il
faut pas hésiter à dire j'ai été sur le
terrain j'étais voir ça j'ai touché j'ai
vu on pourrait s'interroger sur le fait
que du coup je me sens obligé de me
légitime et parce que je suis une femme
faudrait que sur ce canton d'ailleurs
c'est la capacité d' expertise s'est
toujours présentée par les hommes dans
votre métier oui c'est principalement
représentés par des hommes
principalement pourquoi
alors
je pense que c'est la mine par nature et
par construction
c'est un milieu qui est pas un métier
qui est principalement masculin déjà
quand je dis par construction et aussi
sociétalement parlant parce que il ya
des dmm
ddg dire des croyances ou du moins des
des coutumes qui sont liés notamment à
la question de la présence de la femme
en sous terrain avec plein d'hommes donc
vous avez ou drainé aussi un certain
nombre idéologie
mythologiquement
j'ai en tête
quelques visites de terrain ou en fait
on je vais vous donner cet exemple là
que je trouve succulent ça fait rire
tout moi mais c'est pas grave je me
ridiculiser mais c'est pas grave
on va visiter avec six textes la mine de
pozo sautonne qui était en cours de
fermeture qui se trouve dans la vallée
de lalatiana en espagne on est en 2015
et donc c'était en cours de fermeture
donc les mineurs proposait déjà alors
même que la mine n'avait pas encore
fermé des visites pour des touristes et
on a la chance de descendre à 900 mètres
de profondeur avec des mineurs qui en
fait aussi laid dans le temps de travail
qui leur restait avant la fermeture de
la mine entre des activités touristiques
et des activités de fonds pour la
gestion de la fermeture du site
et on me donne en main donc une foreuse
une foreuse à trépied donc c'est ce qui
permet en fait des relais trou en
souterrain donc ça va faire les trous
l'ont dans lequel vous allez mettre la
dynamite et c'est ce qui va vous
permettre à près de faire un tir
d'abattre la roche de récupérer le
minerai etc et on avance
cet appareil faisait 60 kg
j'en fais 45 46 donc on me l'a donnée
dans les mains et il faut savoir que
pour le tenir donc on va le faire vibrer
puisqu'il faut avancer vous allez fort
et voilà et donc les mineurs est à 3
pour le tenir y en a un qui tire la base
que ça vibre il y en a un qui tient la
base 1 qui gère si vous voulez le
l'alignement de la courbe pour que ça
fort au bon endroit et que voilà et puis
vous en avez un autre qui maintient une
partie qui aident pour tenir coi pour
pousser surtout pour pousser pour que ça
avance là sur ce te paradise est étroit
et le mineur me regarde en souriant et
il me dit
allez je te laisse essayer mais bon on
s'entend que c'est un peu ridicule quoi
du coup effectivement il faut lui répond
connard
alors je dis que j'essaye quand même et
on se met à 3 donc deux autres collègues
de six textes et moi même et on s'en
sort pas trop mal avec difficulté seul
mais on s'en sort pas trop mal vous je
me retourne vers le mineur et je lui ai
dit à part votre éventuellement ce que
je peux reconnaître votre musculature
qui est certes impressionnante je pense
qu'il ya votre travail
qu'est ce qui vous différencie vous de
nous en fait dans le travail de la mine
et il m'a regardé en souriant et il m'a
dit on m'a jamais posé la question et du
coup je me la pose ray pour la suite
parce qu'au départ j'aurais répondu que
tout mais qu'en même temps que l'on posé
la question je sais plus
et cette expérience un peu alors on a
quand même galéré un c pour ça je me
suis un peu ridiculisé parce que bon
voila mais
cette expérience en fait elle est
intéressant de ce que je vous disais un
peu sur voila moi je me souviens très
bien de
mon enseignant en maths sup maths spé
qui nous expliquait que globalement
c'était quand même pas très malin de
faire maths sup maths spé quand on était
une femme parce que bon c'est quand même
connu et quantifier que les femmes n'ont
pas de capacité d'abstraction
mathématiques ou encore que voit la fin
puis alors les boutades les allusions
les comparaisons avec vos collègues
masculins ils sont études c'était quoi
l'étude de gros roger c'est ça
non je ne sais pas c'était les titres
roger moore tous les cas je peux pas
vous dire mais en fait c'est des choses
qui sont véhiculés ou par exemple le
fait que mon moi il s'avère que dans mon
parcours j'ai eu la chance de travailler
pour l'expert après mine de l'état sur
des questions d'évaluation de risques
sanitaires et environnementaux
bon bah
vous êtes expert après midi de l'état
donc vous incarnez quelque chose aux
yeux tous et des gens peu importe qu'ils
étaient peu importe leur place mais
c'était des gens qui nous voyaient
arriver moi j'allais présenter les
étudiants me disait vous êtes stagiaires
ou un café un café je prendrai un café
et ouais un doublé et est en fait du
coup j'en parle avec ironie aujourd'hui
parce que ça aussi beaucoup construit la
façon dont moi je vois l'importance de
la civilisation ses métiers je pense que
les femmes elles ont complètement leur
place personnellement moi ça fait 15 ans
que je travaille sur ce sujet j'adore
travailler ce sujet c'est à ma passion
le endroit où je me sens le mieux au
monde quand chez nous ou minsk par est
délirant mais c'est comme ça et je pense
que les femmes elles ont toute leur
pertinence à faire avancer ces questions
autant que les hommes même si
effectivement la cité pas d'usagé il ya
des métiers comme ça aussi annoncé qu'il
ya moins de femmes qui travaillent pas
dans le domaine du btp - deux femmes qui
travaillent dans le domaine de la mine
mais je pense que leurs femmes ont toute
leur place c'est vrai aussi que de toute
façon le voit la féminisation quatre de
plus en plus de géologues ya beaucoup il
ya par exemple ça dépend aussi des
secteurs vous avez plus de femmes dans
l'hydrogéologie qu dans la géologie
minière ou dans la géologie pétrolières
dont je pense que les choses avancent
dans le bon ordre moi j'ai vécu une
période où il y avait encore beaucoup de
sexisme et beaucoup de machisme oui par
rapport à la place de la femme donc
je me souviens aussi de visites de
terrain parce que voilà comme vous le
disais bas ça fait 15 ans que je visite
des mines alors déjà sur mon temps
professionnel quand j'ai eu l'occasion
de le faire avec six textes puisque tous
les ans depuis 2015 si ce texte passe
une à deux semaines à l'étranger pour
aller visiter des sites miniers en
exploitations fermées ou en prévision
quand ils vous voient débarquer ils ont
peur ils ont pas peur y cache un peu la
poussière sous le tapis il vous montre
pas les gens qui se prennent des
cailloux d'aider des gens qui vont pas
bien tout est beau tout est propre vous
arriver comme ça sans votre casquette ou
commencé à poser des questions comment
ça se passe quand on va visiter des
sites miniers en exploitation ça se
passe toujours assez bien déjà parce que
on parle le même langage c'est notre
métier on a le même vocabulaire et aussi
parce que comme je vous le disais en
introduction on n'est pas dupe sur les
limites de notre capacité à agir pour
pouvoir rendre cette filière
alors verte on n'en parle même pas mais
plus vertueuse en fait donc on sait
quelles sont les difficultés de gestion
de déchets de gestion d'exhaure ne
domine hier de gestion d'effluents
gazeux
pourrait longtemps parlé de la question
de la métallurgie qui est liée à la mine
pour nous
donc déjà le fait qu'on parle le même
langage et que en fait bien qu'on ait
des positionnements différents sur la
question environnementale ou la question
de la gestion des risques au des
conséquences ce qui nous à ce qui nous
rapproche dans le dialogue avec des gens
qui sont du secteur ce qu'on a la même
passion
ces convocations de faire des trous
[Rires]
alors moi ma passion ma passion elle est
très similaire à beaucoup de géologues
d'exploration et d'exploitation que je
connais c'est plus la passion avant de
faire détrousser de la passion du
caillou
c'est assez dommage que les gens s'y
intéressent pas davantage puisque c'est
un métier absolument incroyable la
géologie
c'est un déjà les forces en présence les
périodes de temps sur lesquels se font
ces phénomènes géologiques
la pluralité la diversité des minéraux
des matières premières minérales qu'on
peut trouver
enfin c'est vraiment un monde incroyable
moi j'ai la passion de la géologie avoir
d'abord la passion de la mine j'ai eu la
passion de la mine assez rapidement
parce que parce que la mine c'est encore
un autre monde dans le monde de la
géologie quoi vous avez des géologues
qui sont spécialisées dans le stockage
de co2 d'autres qui sont spécialisés
dans le btp d'autres voilà qui sont
spécialisés dans la joaillerie voire
même d'autres qui sont spécialisés dans
les démarches assurantielle où les
banques pour pour la gestion avec les
grandes et grands exploitants miniers
donc la géologie c'est un très vaste
monde je sais que nous ce qu'il fait foi
souvent dans les gens que je côtoie
c'est la passion du caillou en fait
c'est incroyable
enfin cesser comme on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est loris et le sait à la base
de notre modèle de développement c'est
comme ça qu'on a qu'on s'est construit
c'est
un monde apprend à découvrir ces des
phénomènes d'une importance d'une force
d'une
je pesne voyez à trouver certains boom
il y aura t'il qui caractérise en fait
le monde alors certes qui est le monde
minéral quoi c'est pas la plance la
plante qui pousse c'est pas l'oiseau qui
se pensent qu'ils se posent sur la
branche d'arbre mais pour autant c'est
un monde absolument incroyable les
forces telluriques en présence folle
donc je pense que ce qui nous lie et ce
qui fait qu'on arrive assez facilement à
discuter avec des exploitants c'est
notre capacité aussi à parler le même
langage et en fait ils savent que de
toute façon ce que l'on dit est vrai il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté je veux dire la
seule approche de six textes quand on
dit non mais là il ya un problème là
paravent ou s'est renseigné mille fois
on a lu on a vérifié on a vérifié qu'ils
avaient des dizaines d'auteurs qu'ils
étaient d'accord avant de pouvoir
affirmer ce qu'on disait quand
aujourd'hui moi je dis un problème avec
les digues et que c'est complètement
hallucinant qu'aujourd'hui et entre 4 à
5 rupture de digues leurs parents parce
que ça fait 12 ans que je m'intéresse
aux ruptures de digues que j'y rencontre
est insuffisamment de gens pour me
rendre compte qu'il y avait des
aberrations que j'ai même rencontré des
gens du pneu qui ont travaillé j'ai eu
la chance de rencontrer ces personnes
qui ont travaillé sur la fameuse étude
de 2010 est expliqué ce que ce plu
attardons le programme des nations unies
pour l'environnement qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui de plus en plus humaine
environnement d'ailleurs
donc ça veut dire que quand nous on
annonce qu'il ya un problème bah je sais
qu'on est respecté par beaucoup aussi
d'exploitants parce que ils savent qu'on
travaille énormément content hier pas ça
de notre chapeau aux abois aller
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire ça ça va
pas dans la mine non ce que nous on
dénonce à six textes et les exploitants
le savent ils le savent très bien c'est
les pratiques inacceptables
c'est le moment où on a basculé de la
gestion d'un modèle productif qui certes
était impactant mais compréhensible à un
moment où on a basculé complètement avec
des impacts qui sont gravissimes et des
échelles qui sont démentiels c'est ce
moment là qui nous intéresse est en tous
les cas c'est celui qu'on veut
caractérisée donc en général ça se passe
extrêmement bien et il faut savoir aussi
que lors de ses visites de terrain
en fait on va rencontrer on va donner
autant d'importance dans le temps que
l'on donne aux exploitants et aux
mineurs aux familles et aux populations
affectées aux élus aux représentants
régionaux députés etc de façon à avoir
une vision pleine et entière parce que
souvent ce qui manque dans beaucoup de
discours minier si on parle de la mine
du métal etc tous ces cons à cette
approche si vous voulez
extrêmement polarisé de la problématique
minière au regard de mon game in 1 il ya
du métal 1 il ya des besoins voilà je
vais je vais switcher un peu
avec notre modèle de développement
exponentiel est ce que la terre va
réussir à fournir pour une transition
énergétique
est ce que on a pas on n'est pas tombé
dans une société qui n'a plus les moyens
de ses ambitions
je parle en terme d'affaiblissement je
termine je parle en termes d'inflation
des prix sur les métaux je parle en
termes d'inflation sur l'énergie
utilisée pour sortir les métaux de la
terre est ce qu'on n'a pas arriver en
fait ce point de non retour où on est en
train de courir comme un poulet sans
tête et on courrait aux cours et aux
cours pour fournir des points de
croissance pour fournir fournir fournir
est-ce que vous avec votre avis de
géologues quand on entend nos politiques
dire on va passer à tout électrique on
va avoir des voitures électriques
partout des trottinettes électriques des
tabourets électrique et j'en passe
ça va arriver
est-ce que c'est pas en fait utopique et
c'est pas une façon politico
politiciennes de dire vous inquiétez pas
emmener d'énergie etc ce qui crée de
l'inflation tant sur les matières
premières alimentaires que sur le prix
de la part de faire que vous mettez dans
votre maison est ce qu'on est en train
d'arriver sur un système qui est en fait
déjà morts parce que la transition
énergétique et la transition écologique
si vous me racontez que on se fait des
amis qui réouvre des centrales à charbon
pour pouvoir fournir de l'électricité au
fond son trou ça va pas le faire est-ce
qu'on n'est pas sur un système qui
course en tête et puis il faut pas un
changement de paradigme
complètement complètement
comme je vous disais déjà le fêtait
c'est que par rapport aux usages on va
dire et régulier or transition ce que je
décrivais tout à l'heure qui sont dans
le quotidien on était déjà sur des taux
de croissance qui étaient énormes et qui
étaient notamment portés mais pas
seulement donc je parle toujours pas de
la transition je parle déjà de base qui
était notamment par portée par le
développement de certains pays émergents
qui en fait représente le secteur de la
construction par exemple
déjà décroissance métalliques sur
certaines filières qui sont énormes déjà
de base
ce qu'on constate effectivement vous
avez raison d'insister là dessus c'est
que aujourd'hui on parle de deux
transitions la transition digital ou la
transition numérique et la transition
énergétique
faudra pas trop ce que c'est que la
transition numérique si le fait de
passer à beaucoup de mairies 4 et
beaucoup de numérique c'est une
transition on dit
mais je vois pas trop aujourd'hui ce
qu'il ya dans l'ems terme de transition
on a juste une augmentation rapide dans
tous les secteurs de l'existence depuis
le milieu professionnel au milieu
personnel
on a une espèce de 2,2 d'ingérence
permanent du monde numérique donc si
c'est une forme de transition
admettons
pour l'instant je mets de côté la
question du numérique clé pour moi
spécifique donc on va parler uniquement
de la transition énergétique
la transition énergétique
effectivement ça a été le un des points
d'ancrage c'est notamment un rapport de
la banque mondiale de 2017 qui nous est
enfin qui a expliqué en disant voilà
nous
on a fait des scénarios à partir des
accords de paris donc avec un scénario
de degré 44 % d'énergies renouvelables
on a même des visées ce que ça pouvait
représenter en termes de métaux sur
trois technologies parce qu'on va pas
tout les prendrons comprend l'éolien le
solaire et le stockage donc le stockage
batteries stationnaires
donc il identifie un certain nombre de
métaux intéressant déjà de constater que
dans les métaux les seuls mais originaux
de la liste qui est retenu par la banque
mondiale c'est l'indium et lithium
sinon c'est que des métaux que vous
connaissez aluminium plomb zinc cuivre
et on y va argent
chrome nickel
donc premier enjeu c'était ce rapport de
la banque mondiale sur la transition et
puis alors on a suite à cela la banque
mondiale qui en fait lancé une campagne
excusez moi j'en souris parce qu'il ya
tellement de choses drôles dans cette
campagne ça devient vraiment drôle à la
fin ironiquement parlant qui s'appelle
la campagne climate smart mining
donc en temps en temps des
jeux c'est pas la mine intelligentes ont
la mine qui gère intelligemment le
climat enfin peu importe donc c'est une
grosse campagne de la banque mondiale
vous avez des représentations que
j'encourage à les voir parce que c'est
assez merveilleux vous avez des dessins
qui ressemblent à des walt disney en
verre et en bleu on vous présente la
mine éoliennes etc
parallèlement à partir d année 2010 à
peu près peut-être même avant mais le
nombre de publications menthe vous avez
de nombreuses injonctions qui arrive sur
tous les secteurs industriel et pas
seulement la mine en disons vous avez
une obligation de réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre vous débrouiller
comme vous voulez or il s'avère que le
secteur minier est excessivement
énergivores à lui seul il a valu 8 à 10%
de l'énergie mondiale et rien que le
secteur minier or béton j'insiste parce
que nous on a su que le béton or béton
c'est 4 à 7% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre maclean's est 2020 c'est
les derniers chiffres que moi j'arrive à
trouver donc on a dit bon messieurs
dames il faut que vous vous mettiez au
travail il faut vous rédigez vous
réduisiez pardon vos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
donc on voit des rapports qui promeuvent
l'utilisation
faut que je risque dramatique
on va donc créer des modèles de
développement de l'éolien et du solaire
sur les sites miniers
alors quand je lis ces rapports
notamment un rapport de l' ocde qui vous
explique en fait comme on peut comment à
quel point en fait il faut promouvoir et
déployer les énergies renouvelables sur
les sites mis
très bien alors pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur de quoi on parle par
rapport à ce que vous dites va falloir
il faut mettre quoi beaucoup d'éoliennes
ou pas beaucoup d'éoliennes beaucoup de
panneaux soient pas beaucoup de panneaux
solaires pour alimenter un site minier
en énergie
80% plus de 80 % de la dépense
énergétique d'un site minier c'est le
broyage le petit caillou bureau farid le
caillou gros caillou me enfarinée en
vrai farine d'ailleurs c'est les tailles
de grincer de la farine de la farine là
même que vous avez dans votre cuisine
vraiment bien aux alvéoles pulmonaires
oui c'est ça fait partie des nombreux
problèmes qu'on a donc on va c'est 80%
plus de 80% de de la dépense énergétique
d'un site ni vous rendez compte c'est
uniquement voyage en même temps c'est
tellement pas du tout naturelle et
intuitive de vouloir mettre des amendes
de roche sous forme de farine ce qui est
vrai que c'est quand même hallucinant
quand on prend ce recul a c'est vrai
qu'on dit oui il ya un problème va
dépenser de l'énergie une mine une une
une mine moyenne d'or une seule j'en
prend qu'une 2015 y en avait 3 199 en
exploitation j'en prends une production
moyenne 15 tonnes ou une production
moyenne vrac 1,9 tonne on a pris trois
grammes par tonne peu importe les stats
et on a fait un certain nombre
d'hypothèses
avec six textes on a déterminé d'après
publications scientifiques qu'on a
réussi à regrouper que c'était
l'équivalent de la consommation
énergétique de 30 mille foyers en france
trente mille foyers en france
c'est à dire que une mise moyenne dans
l'année c'est il faut mettre le parc
éolien et où le parc solaire qui
permettent d'alimenter 39 foyer pour
envoyer un pas perdre de temps
donc quand on a vu ça à six textes si
dans les années 2000 17 dès que le
rapport de la banque mondiale est sortie
on la lui on attirera c'est quoi cette
histoire puis alors après on a comparé
avec les autres on sait bien mais c'est
drôle déjà il ya quand même un truc
amusant pourrait presque avoir un
système shadoks en fête ou du courant
gros ben on va exploiter des mines pour
produire du cuivre éventuellement alors
le silicium qui est un peu particulier
parce qu'il est un peu particulier on va
prendre du cuivre on va prendre du
nickel
voilà donc je vais prendre des métaux un
peu classique pourquoi les trucs dont on
a surtout besoin de la transition
énergétique quoi et puis on va prendre
ces métaux l'un on va les extraire et
puis du coup on va en faire des métaux
puis ensuite des éléments qui vont faire
des énergies renouvelables qui vont
alimenter en énergie des mines qui vont
extraire des métaux et on recommence
donc ça c'était notre premier paradoxe
en herbe ont énergiquement parlant
c'est quand même bizarre comme modèle
mais bon ça peut tourner à l'infini
comme ça dans l'absolu ensuite j'ai eu
un deuxième enjeu qui nous intéressait
c'était de dire comme je voulais
mentionné précédemment comment diable
est-il possible de faire reposer un
modèle avec des éoliennes ou des
panneaux photovoltaïques alors avec des
technologies différentes annonces en
temps tu as plein de dick technologie
différente dans la batterie stationnaire
dans les cellules photovoltaïques ou
dans l'éolien en fonction de la taille
du mas de la puissance machin en
offshore en onshore peu importe
mais en l'occurrence comment on peut
expliquer à tout le monde que c'est
clairement une énergie verte alors que
tu as comme tout ce qu'on fait au
quotidien javaux vous avez une machine
vous avez du métal quoi le savais avant
quand on faisait une voiture avant même
d imaginer lui mettre une batterie basse
avant on savait déjà qu'il ya du métal
dedans et beaucoup de personnes qui le
découvre malheureusement aujourd'hui on
le savait depuis longtemps c'est pas
suffisant
[Rires]
ça me fait penser à quelqu'un qui va
demander tous les combien ça allait
repousser le métal dans la mine une
conférence je savais pas quoi répondre
que ça repousse et du coup je lis pas
très très très longtemps
on parle pas dans on ne parle pas
d'année pardon bref donc le deuxième
paradoxe il était là c'était 60 bourses
sa scolarité
mais du coup c'était drôle dzeko
deuxième sacre on pousse tous les
combien la saison qu'ils disent lire
maintenant il n'était pas dans un
ministère en plus maintenant c'était un
une personne que j'avais rencontré très
gentil par ailleurs dans une conférence
mais du coup c'est drôle qu'on nous pose
cette question de bien penser que
s'accroît ça repousse tous les combien
c'est un baobab le truc bien c'est non
non ça pousse pas enfin si mais enfin si
non non ça ne pousse même pas offert aux
énergies vertes pour faire des trous
dans le sol qui font tout à fait donc
voilà donc le deuxième enjeu c'était se
dire bah en fait il ya un certain
paradoxe mais en même temps sincèrement
ce paradoxe si nous chanter - même si je
sais que ça a beaucoup choqué des gens
quand vous connaissez la matérialité de
votre quotidien et puis de toutes les
autres machines qui nous entoure enfin
je veux dire moi quand je monte dans un
train j'ai une idée assez claire et
nette de ce en quoi je monte quoi un jeu
mais le métal y en a partout donc ces
paradoxes nous choquer - mais malgré
tout on devrait plutôt rester sur le
premier en dix ans mais on va tourner
comme ça pendant longtemps et puis avec
le temps
on s'est dit mais son bon les gars en
fait
parce que ce qu'ils ont dit c'est qu'ils
ont dit il faut absolument relancer
l'activité minière parce qu'il ya une
transition écologique en cours et que la
l'urgence c'est l'urgence climatique
alors du coup les gens se disent à paris
vivait effectivement mais une urgence
climatique lui il faut limiter les
émissions co2 arriver il faut faut
relancer paris puisqu'il faut des
éoliennes des véhicules électriques et
j'en passe bien il faut relancer
l'activité unia qu'il ya des gens qui
ont dit mais attendez attendez attendez
parce que à un moment donné quand on va
faire le bilan sur les matières
premières sur le transport etc alors
certes et encore c'est pas tout le temps
le cas on parlera des véhicules
électriques vous allez peut-être avoir
moins d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais au moment au moment de votre
usage c'est à dire vous en tant que
consommateur si vous faites votre bilan
sur l' usage du produit de cette nuit ça
fonctionnera mais sur l'amont et sur
laval on en parle ou pas
d'accord on en plein ça fait de la pub
ça fait pas bien
donc on n'en parle pas donc du coup on
s'est dit mais en fait c'est
extraordinaire ce qu'il ya des gens qui
nous est oui mais du coup moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus aux questions
minières parce que je me suis rendu
compte que c'était nécessaire et c'est
sincère que c'était nécessaire pour la
transition ah oui non mais attendez
alors est ce qu'on peut déjà expliqué à
tout le monde que c'est nécessaire pour
le transport que c'est nécessaire pour
l'agriculture que c'est nécessaire pour
la défense que c'est nécessaire pour
l'aérospatiale on va peut-être commencer
par ça alors certes c'est nécessaire
pour la transition écologique mais pas
que mme affectivement c'est quand même
beaucoup moins glamour je pense expliqué
qu'on a besoin de tendre plus de pont
pour assurer l'alimentation au
réfrigérateur du monde entier plutôt que
d'une éolienne parce qu'une éolienne
c'est quand même dix fois plus sexy
qu'un réfrigérateur
ou qu'une ampoule d'ailleurs et on en
reparlera des ampoules parce que j'ai
une dent contre les ampoules donc
du coup c'était l'idée c'était nous ce
dont on s'est rendu compte c'est que si
vous voulez il ya eu une évolution
discursive mais vraiment dans le
discours public on a de plus en plus
associés et c'est vrai vous avez raison
il ya des auteurs qui ont fait des
excellents travaux 2020-2021 je pense
notamment à un chum chercheuse qui
s'appelle derisbourg sao qui a fait des
travaux extrêmement intéressant
justement sur le lien dans notamment
dans tous les l'approchent discursive et
normatives autour du lien transition et
emine il ya un nouveau concept
d'ailleurs qui est née qu'on appelle le
green extractives isen donc
l'extractivisme vert en fait qui en fait
est liée en fait qui a été mis en place
par la société civile internationale qui
dénonce les pratiques
graves de l'industrie minière en dix ans
en fait il ya un rapport notamment que
je vous incite aussi à regarder un
rapport de war on want de 2021 qui
traite de ces questions et en
l'occurrence dans ce rapport ils le
décrivent très bien en disant ce que
disent les auteurs c'est de dire non
pendant des années des années on a lutté
contre les pratiques zina ses tables du
secteur industriel on a lutté pour que
les pratiques changent pour que les
choses s'améliorent pour les gens qui
habitent autour pour pour les gens qui
vivent directement ou indirectement
du de la mine quoi est ce que vous allez
trouver un moyen de nous faire c'est de
créer une espèce de vision des choses
qui en fait tu as aussi la relance
minière à la transition
verdonck et aux verts se modifie et aux
verts et au vert et alors là c'est alors
c'est plus que magnifique c'est même
scandale up mon autre pinault à 6 sec
c'est scandaleux parce que parce que
déjà c'est malhonnête des métaux il y en
a besoin partout pourquoi est ce que
vous faites pas la promotion des
réfrigérateurs ou des google rond là les
trucs où on parlait voilà pourquoi ne
fait pas la promotion de tout ça
pourquoi vous faites uniquement la pop y
allant avec en plus une sémantique
enfin un vocabulaire qui est extrêmement
particulier quand on regarde les textes
encore une fois je me suis basé sur des
textes très très bon il ya aussi un art
kirsch qui en parle enfin il ya
plusieurs auteurs qui soit anthropologue
et sociologue qui est qui qui décrivent
ça moi je suis pas ni anthropologue et
sociologue donc j'écoute les chercheurs
qui en parlent et qui vous explique en
fait les liens dans le discours à voir
comment on construit des discours autour
de ce lien transition mines donc la mine
de cuivre qui a toujours été une mine de
cuivre et dieu sait que les mines de
cuivre sont problématiques un pire que
d'autres dont celui propre et bien du
coup elle est devenue mines verte mais
mines verte mais en vrai ça vous avez
des publications parfois être gonflé
pour écrire ça quand même enfin moi je
peux écrire plein de choses sur les
mines et aline verte quand même si
depuis ces quelques couleurs
seulement pour un des deux clubs cliff
duo christian dunks et bleu
mais oui mais du coup bah oui certes
vous avez raison de dire quand vous vous
quand je comprends tout à fait ce que
vous dites en disant basse et une bonne
excuse ou une bonne façon de faire léger
revendre ça aussi à la population
si on leur dit voilà la transition
énergétique la transition verte la
transition green c'est sexy on va vers
l'avenir on regarde en avant on va
protéger les bébés phoques sur la
banquise
on va sauver les insectes c'est
vachement bien continue on continue on
continue mais mais il faut bien prendre
le contrôle de la dialectique c'est dans
tous les secteurs au départ le tabac
c'était bon pour la santé
puis les mentalités changent eux
moi je trouve que cet exercice
dialectique il est malhonnête parce que
la réalité elle n'est pas là la réalité
elle est complètement ailleurs je peux
comprendre en fait qu'on dise aux jambes
à vous projeter quelque part et donc il
faut que vous croyez en transition je
suis pas en train de dire que je suis
anti éoliennes ni anti panneaux solaires
s'est absolument pas mon propos diable
mais c'est que les scénarios qui sont
aujourd'hui présentées ils sont
complètement irréaliste pourquoi l'autre
pourquoi prenons un exemple j'ai prendre
quelque chose qui a
une espèce de fer de lance de six textes
qu'elle véhicule électrique prenons le
véhicule électrique parce qu'on nous en
parle tant bon alors pourquoi c'est un
problème
attention vous allez vous fâcher à
cannes hidalgo
jacquet l'été elle m'a forcé à mettre ma
voiture au rebut le fidèle destrier
14 ans 108 km pas pu y aller on peut
plus utiliser ces fonds nous reprend la
seule voiture qui est vraiment
écologique c'est le sel prônons prod et
pas
celles qu'on utilise le plus longtemps
possible ou le moins souvent possible
sur l'emploi c'est fou ce qu'on achète
d'occasion par exemple qu'on répare
on est pas dans la merde quand même
pour parler
des projets des programmes irréalisable
les politiques ont pris le contrôle de
la dialectique parce que le véhicule et
je suis désolé je vais sortir un peu de
mon cadre le véhicule électrique c'est
simplement pour éviter les maladies
pulmonaires en ville pour que les gens
ils continuent d'y continuer de
travailler comme des esclaves
sait on x
extra extra territorialise notre
pollution chez les pauvres ou chez les
pays qui sont bien dictatoriaux quand la
riviera devient violette c'est pas grave
parce que c'est des petits chinois qui
vont se baigner dans ainsi de suite
c'est la politique occidentale a calqué
son discours sur vous inquiétez pas voté
pour moi demain ce sera plus cher les
modes les boîtes continuons de volée et
les pigeons auront toujours des
des moignons pour marcher
pourquoi c'est irréaliste en terme en
termes de soutenabilité pourquoi déjà ce
que vous disiez sur le fait que ça
permet aux gens de mieux respirer
demandé à l'agencé européenne de
l'environnement 2018 elle sort un
rapport sur les véhicules électriques
elle vous dit un véhicule électrique
émet deux fois plus de co2 qu'un
véhicule thermique si on prend en compte
sa fabrication ensuite vous allez voir
les chercheurs allemands
2010 est contrarié sur le modèle caddy
volkswagen pour leur demander eux aussi
leur avis on a un problème les études
qu'anticipe à l'électronique des
véhicules électriques on peux pas vous
donner l'impact à vous dit bah c'est pas
grave je vais aller voir d'autres
personnes vous ne lâchez pas où vous
dites moi et je vais aller voir de trois
heures vous demandez je reviens sur l'
agence environnementale donc elle vous
dit ça elle vous dit aussi
parce que l'agencé environnementale
ailleurs si notre source par contre ce
que je peux vous ressourcer la source
pour les deux fois des missions elle va
me revenir ce que je vais la visualiser
sur mon documents deux notes mais je
veux je vais la retrouver si vous
écoutez le son change oui oui mais je
sais je suis confuse je vous en prie
agences environnementales par contre ça
c'est bien la chanson environnementale
le rapport de 2018 elle vous dit c'est
une fois à deux fois plus d'émissions de
nox nous oxydes d'azoté et de dioxyde de
soufre contenu de la fabrication de
l'électronique qui est présent dedans
ça c'est un véhicule électrique c'est ça
les réalités en fait et ce genre de
discours contrairement à ce qu'on pense
ils sont extrêmement présents
aujourd'hui chez les chercheurs et chez
tous les autres mais en même temps c'est
compréhensible on peut re reprenant une
voiture prenons une voiture ensemble on
va faire l'exercice
en gros il ya quatre grands types de
véhicules dont l'électrification du
véhicule il ya le véhicule thermique que
pour électrifier bon vous avez le hybrid
léger c'est du pipeau
c'est juste pour vous montrer
l'évolution vers l'hybride rechargeable
et après vous avez l'électrique
donc en fait mais tel donc du point de
vue du métal à chaque fois que vous
passez d'un modèle à l'autre vous
augmenter la quantité de métal donc une
voiture thermique ces 20 kg de cuivre
normal ça c'est ofi asset management ces
20 kg de cuivre l'hybride léger
c'est 40 kg de cuivre l'hybride
rechargeable ses 60 kilos de cuivre
l'hybride le véhicule électrique
complètement électrifié ses 80 kg qi
gong en passant du thermique au véhicule
électrique je viens déjà multiplié par
quatre la quantité de cuivre déjà je
commence par là sachant qu du coup comme
j'ai un véhicule électrique pas bien
fort que je leur charge le pot non je
vais aller chercher sur des bornes vous
avez des bornes 20 des stations des
installations de recharge là vous avez
du niveau 1 du niveau 2 du niveau 3
chambres pas prendre le niveau 3 niveaux
trois stations de rechargement d'un
véhicule électrique à peu près 120
véhicules qu'on peut recharger avec une
quantité de cuivre 100 kilos en plus pas
reprise
et là je vous ai pas encore parlé du
réseau qui permet d'électrifier la
fameuse borne de recharge parce que la
bande de recharge malheureusement ne
s'auto alimente pas tout seul donc il
faut qu'elles soient raccordés au réseau
et c'est un garçon qui louera fini avec
lou lectrices tic qui va avec qui vont
passer des résidents et make some
intéresse donc ensuite on va continuer
donc là on a pris le club donc je prends
le truc classique on s'en rend pas
compte mais il ya plein de cuisiner dans
un véhicule c'est bien normal mais
l'électrification du coup appel
fortement le cuivre en principal elle
peut aussi appeler l'argent on
électrifié avec deux ne partent pas
l'argent oui on électrifié avec de
l'argent plus rarement avec de l'or
aussi mais on écrit fit surtout avec de
l'aluminium et du cuivre donc prenons du
cuivre on a multiplié par quatre le club
qui veut jusqu'à nos ondes
ensuite à vous avez à l'intérieur de
votre véhicule on s'entend vous avez
plein plein plein de connectique en
cuivre
on peut prendre alors tout le monde fait
tout un pataquès sur la batterie
on va prendre du coup l'aluminium
pourquoi l'aluminium parce que du coup
vous avez une batterie dans votre vécu
et rigoureux qu'il est lourd à fait
résoudre le problème alors du coup il ya
des gens qu'on réfléchisse mamba léger
on va alléger la carcasse alors
l'association de l'aluminium
l'association européenne de l'aluminium
vous dit en l'occurrence on a déjà
observé une tendance à l'augmentation de
la quantité d'aluminium
jusqu'à 2012 2013 qui est lié au fait
qu'on a un allègement de véhicules parce
qu'en fait on a des vêtements des plus
gros émetteurs autres c'est déjà une
tendance en cours parce qu'ils ont voté
des lois sur le poids des véhicules en
plus tout à fait vous avez tout à fait
raison d'insister là-dessus avec le
véhicule électrique donc on dit on à
déjà / on a multiplié par 3 on était de
mémoire autour de 50 kg d'aluminium par
véhicule on est monté à 140 kg
d'aluminium et donc post-2013 zabala
dans les années à venir avec
l'électrification et cetera on pense
qu'on va au moins multiplient encore par
un ennemi minimum rien qu à
l'électrification allez hop on rajoute
de l'aluminium
bon on va prendre
alors la batterie pas forcément qui
cristallise toutes les tensions la
pauvre
à prendre la vôtre et une batterie de
véhicule électrique seat comme une
batterie 1 vous avez un milieu enfin
vous avez une anode une cathode comme
dans les électronique classique et puis
un un fluide au milieu bon en
l'occurrence et des sels de lithium le
plus soit ce qui pour la rize toute
l'attention c'est la cathode c'est la
cathode parce que c'est elle qui en
général la note et en graphite pour
mémoire aussi
en fonction des technologies à un
véhicule hybride c'est à peu près de
mémoire ça doit être un kilo de grafite
sur 110 kg de graphiques en gros vous
multiplié quasiment par sept ou par dix
la quantité de grafite en passant d'une
technologie à une autre donc là c'est
pareil on n'augmente pas grave on arrive
à la batterie auquel elle cristallise
toutes les attentions parce que c'est
14% enfin c'est à peu près 14 % du coût
de la batterie c'est la cathode c'est
très important c'est savait donc là en
général va falloir mettre des métaux
alors les plus connus seller
nmc les nickel manganèse cobalt
mais il ya toujours de lithium
vous en avez qui ont été développées
notamment sur les modèles s de tesla qui
sont à lithium fer phosphore on pourrait
reparler pourquoi on s'interroge sur
pourquoi faire des liqueurs auxerre
phosphore justement du travail aux
pompiers
non c'est pour être moins dépendant de
nmc c'est à dire
alors une zoé petites voitures qui
correspond à la visite voilà une zoé
c'est en moyenne 7 kg du coup de lithium
11 kilos de cobalt 11 kilos de manganèse
et 34 kg dennis k donc ça vous donne un
peu un ordre de grandeur vous allez me
dire bah oui c'est quand même beaucoup
alors par rapport à mon quotidien en moi
ça représente quoi cette affaire là bon
on a dit qu'il y avait à peu près on a
10 11 on va dire entre 10 et 15 peu
importe le chiffre 10 à 15 kg de cobalt
dans une batterie un téléphone portable
en contient cinq à dix grammes
google alors majoritairement de
république démocratique du congo
qui est le pays qui concentre à la fois
le la plus forte production c'est-à-dire
qu'il a plié il produit plus de la
moitié aujourd'hui du cobalt mais il a
aussi ce qu'on appelle les plus fortes
réserves cirque il à 50% de ce qu'on
espère pouvoir exploiter ou de ce qu'on
pense pouvoir exploiter un jour alors
portée des veaux crassier ces gens là
haut qui se prépare
parmi cette production de cobalt en
république démocratique du congo alors
ça dépend des chiffres moi j'ai plutôt
de base et du coup sûr les chiffres
d'amnesty international on estime qu' on
est autour de 40% de la production de
cobalt qui est réalisé dans des
exploitations à petite échelle
le reste du coût étant exploités à
grande échelle voilà pour ça qu'on voit
des russes se balader en afrique un peu
plus ou c wagner comme effectivement je
pense que vous faites est de protéger
vous faites appel à une
une organisation privée
et on pourrait en parler puisque nos
tropiques
non c'est nous qui faisons appel à
désorganiser fondation philanthropique
c'est pas wagner
on pourrait alors parler justement de la
question de la sécurisation des sites
miniers parce que c'est un énorme j'ai
quand je vous entends des nous parler de
deux barrages de rétention de deux bouts
je me disais dans la tête voilà ils
doivent être reçus aussi intelligents
que ceux qui protègent les piscines de
rétention de crayon
radioactifs de combustible de nos
centrales je vous dis je suis sûr qu'ils
ont déployés il battrait antimissile
d'or ils sont super intelligents ces
gens là n'ont ils sont protégés les si
tu me lis contre les attaques
terroristes alors contre ils sont
protégés
et bien ils sont protégés contre les les
gens qui ont des dreadlocks et qui
essayent de de s'enchaîner à des
tracteurs des tractopelles ccg
terroriste
alors lobby midi il y pense que les
écologistes sont des terroristes
on savait que vous m'avez laissé trois
questions en suspens et que je tiens
absolument à y répondre et vous
inquiétez pas j'ai une bonne maman je
répondrai aux trois principales roche
lobby me répéter je vois bien les logis
sont considérés comme des terroristes
c'est de répondre précisément
je pense que le le secteur minier
ne sais pas n'était pas prêt lorsque le
début des revendications
environnementales et le début des
revendications des populations locales à
émerger ils se sont sentis dépassés
l'habitude de graisser la patte des gens
où ils avaient surtout en fait
l'habitude que y est beaucoup moins de
protestation je pense qu'il ya un
décalage entre
actuellement par exemple la conception
la façon dont le secteur minier
considère la société civile est par
exemple le secteur pétrolier si je vais
prendre deux secteurs qui sont vraiment
proches je pense que c'est pas du tout
la même chose parce que il ya eu
beaucoup moins d'interactions aussi
historiquement dire que c'est quand même
assez récent qu'on s'intéresse aux
questions minières quand j'ai fondé
aussi ce texte avec une autre personne
en 2009 on parlait jamais minutes quoi
jamais jamais jamais dans aucune presque
tout le monde s'en fiche et personne ne
s'occupait de cette question 2009
c'était hier l'époque c'était
l'époque donc je pense que gap donc je
dirais que tout ce qui est les
organisations type association ou
organisation non gouvernementale qu'elle
soit à l'échelle locale ou nationale ou
internationale
effectivement on relativement eu peu
d'interactions et que je pense
qu'effectivement il ya eu un décalage il
ya eu un gap comme on dit en anglais
entre les attentes de la société civile
qui sont arrivés massivement et dans
l'état d'esprit dans lequel se trouvait
un certain nombre d'acteurs industriels
ça c'est une chose et là je vous ai
parlé uniquement de certains acteurs là
où l'on considère et on criminalise les
personnes qui luttent y compris
pacifiquement c'est en particulier les
populations locales et les mouvements
nobili mobilisation et ça ne concerne
pas que le pérou
en 2018 si ce texte on est allé en grèce
et on a eu la chance d'assister à des
retrouvailles entre des papas qui
sortait de prison
qui avaient manifesté pacifiquement
contre un projet minier dont peut-être
certains vous aurez peut-être n'est pas
laisser le projet des secours y en a
coûté de thessalonique à l'est de la
grèce
en fait c'est ces gens étaient
agriculteurs ils étaient ils étaient
fermiers ils avaient juste envie de
défendre leur terre et est juste envie
d'expliquer qu'il y avait un problème de
parce qu'il ya déjà eu des problèmes
parce qu'on a déjà connu la mine dans
cette région qu'ont et le déjà victimes
des pollutions anciennes et on en
reparlera j'espère dans cette
intervention si la question des
pollutions anciennes et donc ils
savaient ils ont manifesté le plus
pacifiquement du monde et on quand vous
voyez les motifs sur les jugements chez
les jugements pardon mais vous pleuré ça
c'est une forme de répression arbitraire
et autoritaire d'une forme de
contestation ça a été les secouristes a
été rosia montana en roumanie et plus
largement aujourd'hui ce que disent les
associations qui travaillent dans le
domaine des droits humains ou des
questions sociales ces deux choses la
première c'est que le secteur industriel
tous confondus y compris nucléaires agro
business & company 1 le secteur qui
polarise le plus fin qui est à l'origine
du plus de conflits sociaux ou
environnementaux
c'est le secteur minier
ces 20% des conflits sociaux
environnementaux référencés dans la base
de données e j atlas une publication
scientifique qui a été fait e j atlas
est une base de données cartographique
en ligne qui référence les conflits
sociaux environnementaux excellente
travail extraordinaire notamment avec
l'université de barcelone c'est vraiment
un énorme travail ils vous disent nous
on à 2700 je crois qu'à on en à 573 qui
sont il n'y en a plus d'un pour cent
sont toujours plus longs les écologistes
ou tard d'un sont turbulents
je ne sais pas s'ils sont pas gros
titres mais je les trouve pas
particulièrement turbulents par contre
c'est interrogeant de lire tous secteurs
confondus la mine elle tient le triste
record d'être le premier secteur
impliqué avec 20% ça c'est du domaine du
domaine des socios qui vous disent
énorme augmente conflits sociaux ou
environnementaux qui lie à la mine
et ça va pas s'améliorer qu'on va tous
passer les voitures électriques
non moi je vous préviens ne s'y passe
pas je sais pas qui est ce qui va
obliger à avoir une véhicule électrique
tout lesquels vous assure qu'il n'est
pas né mais en l'occurrence tout ça pour
vous dire que ensuite il ya l'enjeu
humain n'est pas pour le lobby des
moteurs thermiques
la grande force des six textes c'est
qu'elle n'a pas d'intérêt et ça ça
change beaucoup de choses au quotidien
dans la façon dont on appréhende une
problématique avait subi des pressions
par exemple comme les autochtones dans
sa forêt là qui nous envers toute la
journée qu'il peut y laisse pas passer
paye les tracteurs qui nous ennuie cédé
points de pib en moins est ce qu'on vous
a un peu mis la pression comme lui avec
un flingue sur la tête ou une pression
sur sa famille ou des ou des choses
comme ça
je n'ai pas été menacé avec une arme ni
blanche ni
notre type d'armes ça c'est parce que
vous êtes blanche et que vous êtes en
france est ce qu'on vous a mis décroche
pas que dans votre carrière
mais j'ai été épargné parce que
j'ai séparé ma vie professionnelle de
mon investissement associatif c'est à
dire que j'ai considéré qu'il y avait de
monde
aujourd'hui assistex il ya des gens qui
travaillent pas dans l'industrie minière
mais qui en sont soit proche soit qui
travaillent sur ces questions là on sait
qu'ils sont pas dans l'industrie minière
et qui sont anonymes qui travaillent
anonymement d'entre eux protègent
l'identité
parce que ils peuvent pas s'exprimer ils
sont trop peur de perdre leur métier
mais s'ils travaillent pas dans une
industrie mines ça va même au delà des
gens qui nous appellent pour nous
féliciter notre travail alors qu'ils
travaillent dans des gens parient encore
une fois très pas dans l'industrie
minière vitrail sur des questions mia
ils nous appellent pour nous vraiment
c'est super ce que vous avez fait ce
rapport là mais vous savez je peux pas
vous décrire ce que je peux pas laisser
de trace écrite de soutien envers vos
donc en fait c'est pas une pression
c'est un plus tôt pour moi c'est un état
d'esprit c'est à dire que toute personne
si ce texte prend le problème en tiens
c'est à dire qu'on prend la mine les
techniques minières et techniques de
traitement et relargages les effluents
les populations la politique des
finances et on y va et là on va parler
du site minier une fois qu'on a tout
pris on va pouvoir discuter sérieusement
mais d'abord on essaye de comprendre et
on prend l'avis de tout le monde
cette vision là elle est plutôt rare
dire que le fait de dire on va nous on
va sortir de la polarisation laminait
ses finances et on va essayer de
regarder un peu tous les environnements
les implications les conséquences et du
coup à un moment donné si ce texte peu
concluante et là il ya un problème ou la
non ça c'est pas grave le moment où
cette approche je voyais de l'évaluation
du risque et de l'importance des
éléments relativement c'est parce que
vous avez une vision globale de tout ce
qui se passe autour et pas seulement de
votre objet productifs qui doit ramener
temps de retour sur investissement et
c'est donc cette approche-là du coup
elle nous est permise comme je disais on
regarde notre adn n'a pas l'intérêt je
veux dire j'ai pas d'intérêt non lamy ou
qui ont un intérêt dans le mix qu'on n'a
pas non plus d'intérêt à protéger une
forêt où voilà on n'a aucun intérêt on
aide tout on est de la société civile
parce qu'on croit qu' il faut absolument
que cette branche de l'aso site de la
société se réapproprie les questions
minières elles puis elles puissent elles
se défendre et et avoir les mêmes outils
que nous on a pour comprendre les
problématiques mais on n'a pas d'intérêt
donc faut ça pour elle vous raconte ça
parce qu'effectivement je pense que
c'est plus un état d'esprit c'est à dire
que toute personne
aujourd'hui qui
dénonce les pratiques alors encore une
fois on dénonce pas la mine en général
on dénonce certaines pratiques qui sont
bien identifiés et qui sont
particulièrement graves parce qu'il faut
pas tout mais
exactement mais même au delà tout le
monde tout les mêmes pratiques moi quand
j'ai voulu parler franchement vous avez
des associations qui nous contactent le
5 août et on est embêté avec tel rejet
etc moi je regarde les toners ou non
mais les gars
là c'est bon je regarde les toners je
regarde l'environnement gens regardent
la consommation qui en est fait je
rassure les gens disant ne vous
inquiétez pas pour ça par contre quand
il ya des gens qui m'appelle en me
disant ou qu'ils appellent d'autres
personnes et 500 e on a un souci là on a
des dépôts miniers qui on attend de
concentration en plomb ah oui nommé
samiullah ya un problème là non c'est
notre métier pour la plupart d'entre
nous c'est notre formation n'a travaillé
des années là dedans or pas forcément
dans la industrie minérale mais proche
d'elle mais c'est vrai qu'en fait c'est
pour ça que je dis j'ai pas envie de
vous parler de pression même si des
menaces des gens qui disent des choses
franchement on s'en fout un peu mais
voilà je samassa n'est pas très utile en
fait mais on en aura tout le temps parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord et que les gens
ont pas tous la même intelligente
lorsqu'ils atteignent 6 agences pardon
quand lorsqu'ils disent ils expriment
leur désaccord c'est la vie dans la
poudre quelqu'un qui
fonds d'investissement avec une
titrisation produits de certaines mines
et son fonds d'investissement par
exemple l'état qui investit au cas
titrisées qui a dans son portefeuille
des délires
ça l'aide à payer la retraite de ses
fonctionnaires et puis la mine c'est
bien parce que c'est relativement stable
ça
vous êtes mis dans d'antan dans la peau
de quelqu'un qui utilise la mine pour
stabiliser la société les retraites
l'approvisionnement pour les téléphones
portables des ampoules c'est peut-être
nécessaire nom de me mettre dans la peau
de quelqu'un
du coup investi dans ce secteur là et
est donc ok mais supposons que je le
fasse maintenant alors
il faut des coups que je vois comment ça
championnat des choses ans c'est pas
bien ça et de la société savait de
l'écho de l'isaaa de la transition ce
jugement bien bas nonobstant ou alors
vous n'avez pas écouté tout ce que je
vous ai raconté mon vous exagérez c'est
alors pour les usages est pour et pour
la transition on a reparlé si vous
voulez je peux continuer à argumenter
sur le véhicule électrique si vous
n'êtes toujours pas compris non mais
j'aime bien parce que si un jour soit
aidé à l'idée le coup on va bien rigoler
mais par contre je me ferai un plaisir
de vous envoyer toutes mes sources
j'espère bien
et vous verrez ce sera super donc
effectivement quand je me mets dans la
peau d'une personne qui m'explique que
c'est bien
je peux tout à fait comprendre de dia ba
oui effectivement
vous souhaitez investir vous souhaitez
placer votre argent vous avez envie
d'investir là non je dirais pourquoi pas
pourquoi ça ou pourquoi pas autre chose
mais à un moment donné faut être
conscient des réalités c'est à dire que
si vous êtes investisseurs vous avez une
responsabilité
dans ce en quoi vous investissez
je vais vous donner un exemple
la mine une grosse mine en inde
donc c'est un industriel peu importe son
nom qui a voulu développer une grosse
mine de bauxite qui a réussi un
peut-être que vous en avez entendu
parler il ya quelques années et c'était
une grosse mine en inde d'aluminium qui
comprenait une zone d'exploitation une
raffinerie
et elle a été assez connue parce que la
lutte des peuples autochtones qui a été
menée pour protéger leur territoire
et une à la logique a été fait parce
qu'on était à peu près au même moment de
la sortie du premier du premier opus
d'avatar
ils sont bien faire les arcs
et s'en remettent du coup il ya eu un
soutien international massif via
survival et d'autres organisations mais
aussi y compris des réalisateurs des
producteurs de d'avatar parce qu'en fait
il s'avère que cette montagne
dans l'inde elle est sacrée donc il y
avait de l'aluminium dedans mais elle
est sacrée elle pas toucher à cette
montagne et le peuple en question c'est
le peuple autochtone c'est les dongria
kondh vous pourrez regarder et pourquoi
je vous donne cet exemple là parce que
quand
l'équipe de luc besson se dit mémoire
c'est bien luc besson et compagnie ont
commencé à et commencé à faire de la pub
que les toutes les organisations non
gouvernementales ont commencé à en
parler que ça a commencé à savoir
l'échelle internationale en quelques
jours
les investisseurs se sont retirés il ya
quatre milliards d'encours qui sont
parties en une seule fois
et ça c'est un exemple que je trouve
intéressant sur la fragilité des modèles
d'investissement de et c'est valable
aussi par exemple pour
prenons un autre exemple on parlait tout
à l'heure de la catastrophe de boue made
in you en 2019 quand on s'est rendu
compte que l'entreprise concernée
d'hier était à l'origine d'une
catastrophe environnementale et humaine
majeur un qui est considéré quand même
comme une des pires catastrophes au
brésil or malheureusement ils ont vu en
plus indivise épisode gravissime quatre
ans avant
et bien effectivement il ya eu des
investisseurs qui se sont détournés de
l'entreprise et puis il ya eu aussi une
baisse majeure dans les cours de la
société etc alors ça a remonté après on
s'entend ça revient mais ce que je pense
en fait dans ce que même si je ne suis
pas économiste et je ne prétends pas
être maîtrisé un métier qui n'est pas le
mien mais en tous les cas ce que j'en
sais c'est que à plusieurs reprises j'ai
pu constater que si vous avez un énorme
bug sur un set ni ça peut aller très
vite et vous pouvez avoir tout le monde
qui sont vains rapidement qui prend ses
cliques et ses claques qui remet son
argent dans ses valises et qui s'en va
et ça je pense que ce n'est pas à
négliger dans une industrie qui est
régulièrement soumises à des épisodes
des accidents qui sont assez majeur
donc je ne dis pas en fait que ça
fragilise l'investissement en peluche
même pas économiste je vais pas dire ça
bien sûr que non mais en tous les cas ce
que je peux dire c'est que il ya une
responsabilité dans l'investissement et
c'est de dire investir dans du métal
intéressant investir dans la mine
attention la mine certes il ya des
entreprises qui arrivent à faire un
petit peu de mieux en mieux il ya des
entreprises qui essaye de mettre en
place des choses mais globalement enfin
sincèrement quoi c'est quand même les
tout débuts du mien coin on est au début
né du rase-mottes des bonnes pratiques
quoi donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
voilà je vous explique qu'il faut à
dijon donc
je reviens à votre sujet d'avant juste
avant ce vous disiez sur la question de
transition en dix ans
du coup c'est ça que vous m'aviez posé
comme question sur la question de la
transition et
et on était oui voila je me souviens on
en était on était sûrs d'en avant la
transition je veux finir un truc excusez
moi mais paris ce système avait parlé
des pressions ils ont même failli des
environnementalistes et à ce moment là
les diversions mais en l'occurrence ce
que je voudrais dire c'est on a parlé
des associations gouvernementales et non
gouvernementales ou en gros des acteurs
de la société civile qui sont si les
journalistes
les différents acteurs qui entourent si
vous voulez
l'information avec plein de guinée par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir comment sont traités quand je
disais les communautés locales et on a
parlé des conflits sociaux ou
environnementaux mais on n'a pas parlé
d'un fait et pour las quand vous m'avez
parlé de wagner ça va faire le lien
c'est qu'on n'a pas parlé de la question
ces populations et de la criminalisation
des populations qui sont dans
l'environnement des sites miniers
le secteur minier et extractif alors
peut-être pour certains vous en souvenez
je vais me revenir un petit peu en
arrière 2006
john reade j à l'époque et représentant
spécial du secrétaire du secrétaire
national des nations unies le secrétaire
général des nations unies et il est dit
un rapport sur la question des droits de
l'homme sociétés transnationales et
entreprises
je vais essayer d'être au plus près de
la citation mais le rapport est
accessible sur internet et j'ai se
déplie près de la citation c'est
en gros les industries extractives
pétrole gaz mines
globalement sont de loin à l'origine du
plus d'abus en matière de droits humains
lourd
deuxième ou troisième page du texte un
peu après continue il dit
ils sont d'ailleurs donc ils sont treize
en tête en termes d' abus c'est à dire
en fait son opposition en termes de
nombre mais ensuite ils ajoutent quelque
chose il dit ils sont
à l'origine des pires abus certains
étant
équivalent aux comparables à de la
complicité de crime contre l'humanité
on est à la page 6 du document faut
tenir bon et à
donc vous lisez ça vous dit ok et donc
après john de rugy jeunes rue jean dit
en gros enfin c'est pas forcément john
ruggie qui a rédigé ce document dans
tous les cas il était rapporteur pour le
secrétaire national et ensuite il dit de
nous il ya quatre moteurs
il ya
les forces privées ou publiques
qui sécurise le site minier
il ya les violations des droits des
travailleurs
il y a la situation des populations
des populations affectées et en
particulier des peuples autochtones
et je crois que c'est tout
et alors cette question de la
militarisation alors moi personnellement
j'ai jamais compris moi je suis désolé
je répète je détenais
le secteur minier est un des secteurs
qui est assez unique en son genre en
terme de sécurisation
avec souvent des forces privées des
forces de sécurité privées ou aux
alentours des sites miniers alors on
pourrait me dire mais vous comprenez
prendre une mine d'or un lingot ça fait
ça à la fin c'est facile c'est on peut
le mettre dans la poche bon mais enfin
t'as pas besoin d'une kalachnikov pour
surveiller un lingot d'or mais bon
admettons admettons maintenant de plus
en plus en fait comme vous avez des
mouvements de plus en plus de mouvements
de protestation mais il éventuellement
même des mouvements pacifistes ou les
gens sont à 500 m 1 il ya une tendance à
la section sécurisation donc soit par
des services privés
soit par des services publics c'est à
dire que c'est l'état qui met à
disposition sa police où son armée pour
sécuriser des zones
et le cc si vous voulez ce phénomène que
je connais plus dans la mine que dans
d'autres secteurs en tous les cas a pris
une ampleur suffisamment important pour
qu'il fasse partie des premiers moteurs
identifiés par john d'origine à l'époque
et qui est identifié comme un des
moteurs majeurs aussi par de nombreux
sociologues et en même temps vous mettez
des des gens qui ont des armes
et qui ont un peu tous les droits pour
éviter l'accès aux sites miniers quoi
donc voit donc ça c'est un problème de
droit humain majeur et or
malheureusement la mine elle est souvent
pour l'opposition quoi en termes de
conflits sociaux environnementaux et en
termes de droits humains
en termes de droits humains toujours je
peux vous donner cet exemple et c'est
pour ça que quand je regardais
sincèrement vous disais tout à l'heure
où l'industrie mire c'est pas une
industrie comme les autres les
sociologues vous dise c'est une
industrie qui explique et unique au
monde en ce qui concerne l'
expropriation dire qu'on n'a pas d'autre
équivalent dans les secteurs industriels
sur l'expropriation l'euro n'a pas
aujourd'hui de statistiques
internationales sur le nombre de
déplacements forcés associés à
l'activité minière par contre on est
souvent sur 20 sur des gros sites on est
souvent sur des chiffres au total qui
tourne autour d'une part dont dix à
trente mille personnes
donc on parle souvent en me lis mon
dizaines de milliers personnes alors
effectivement il ya un cas grasberg en
indonésie mines extrêmement connue vous
en avez un autre en tanzanie auquel je
pense moi admettons que vous avez des
cas c est gros sites mais les
expropriations passé où les déplacements
forcés de population ce sont des
phénomènes qui sont assez courant dans
le secteur minier et vous avez pas
obligé pas obligés de changer de
continent vous pouvez aller dans un pays
frontalier au nôtre l'allemagne la mine
de charbon de hambach dont certains ont
beaucoup entendu parler parce que à les
coller à une mine primaire qui est parti
des dernières mines primaires du pays
cette mine là en fait là actuellement
elle a déplacé plusieurs milliers de
personnes ces mines de charbon à ciel
ouvert et elle envisage d'en déplacer
encore plusieurs milliers au québec
alosi et vous vous rendez pas compte
vous n'êtes pas content mais il faut les
bouger c'est petit jo parce que la mine
c'est le sens de notre économie et si
j'ai pas de sens dans mon économie pas
il va y avoir des gens chômage et puis
on va rentrer en crise économique et
puis vous rendez pas compte si je mets
de la police un peu partout autour des
mid parce que c'est un secteur
stratégique
en termes de guerre économique et vous
rendez pas compte alors ces petits
écologistes avec leurs cheveux mal coupé
mal rasé c'est normal un petit coup de
crosse de kalachnikov histoire défaire
des bougies et puis hop on en parlera
plus parce que ils menacent mon économie
mais pour une pib
mon système de retraite
vous rendez pas compte oui mais ils
menacent ces gens là il menace peut-être
votre pib votre économie votre système
de retraite puis je dois me fait rêver
en quatre
temps bien j'entends bien vos
préoccupations vous inquiétez pas nancy
dont certains marchés qui vont financer
des camps sont inhumés au delà j'entends
tout à fait ce que vous dites mais
je fais la caricature oui mais mais je
comprends mais ce que je suis jolie
bague vous êtes enfin les gens le sont
parce qu'ils ont une dynamique qui
effectivement de dire
la navette ont dit la mine elle est
centrale dans le modèle économique
et c'est là qu'il va y avoir un moment
on va switcher vers d'autres
considérations c'est qu'on n'a jamais
dit que c'était la mine qui était au
coeur de la matérialité de notre monde
on a dit que c'était les métaux
auquel j'ai dit que j'ai dit que le
monde était matériellement fondée sur
des métaux donc je reprenais cet ex
parce qu'ils sont dix clubs elles sont
dix clubs
si vous voulez on peut parler de
l'esclavagisme et de toutes les
prisonniers dans les mines si vous
voulez plein de cas je vous vois la
meilleure mais vous m'avez posé une
question avant tellement de choses
non je dis vous disiez que vous faisiez
l'avocat du diable en disant je suis
bien content que vous finissez oui mais
vous avez dit deux choses aussi sur la
question économique est donc ce
stratégie et l'axé stratégique et c est
justement en fait c'est intéressant
parce que voyez bien quand on en parle
même nom quand on en parle là on fait
une association systématique mines
métaux
c'est pas la même chose
la mine est une voie
d'approvisionnement en métal c'est
certainement celle qu'on connaît le plus
et c'est une réalité mais c'est pas la
seule on cite l'un ya le recyclage et
puis après ben il ya globalement la
consommation c'est à dire que vous me
dites à l'instant moi j'ai envie d'un
modèle économique qui soient pérennes et
qui soit 5 qui soit je sais je sais pas
ce que vous mettiez non là dedans mais
supposons j'ai envie que ça d'avoir une
société qui vit bien et c'est dans une
société qui vit bien
1 on regarde le métal pour ce qu'il est
avant d'aller cherche à se poser la
question de savoir s'il faut à
l'extraire soit l'autre bout du monde
soit chez nos voisins ou celle où la
première question qu'il faut déjà
pouvoir se poser deux c'est à dire de
quelle métaux avons nous besoin pour le
fameux modèle économique est sain dont
on parle et la question est d'autant
plus importante puisque le day 1 des
derniers rapports qui est sorti une
semaine qui était censée répondre à
cette question apparemment ne veut pas
être publié qui sait le rapport va qui
en fait et travaillant dans un rapport
sur la sécurisation des
approvisionnements
ça nous aurait été utile mais on nous
ait fait a expliqué à tout le monde aux
journalistes et la société civile que le
rapport ne pouvait pas être rendus
publics c'est bercy qui l'a expliqué
dans un communiqué de presse parce que
il y avait des données qui étaient
confidentielles et qui concernait le
secteur des secteurs stratégiques de
l'industrie donc on ne pouvait pas avoir
accès au dos ça s'est tellement groupe
préparez-vous à la guerre mais on veut
pas le dire
c'est parce qu'il ya dans ce rapport on
ne le fait pas et mettre des conclusions
c'est pas je sais pas ce qu'il ya dedans
par contre c'est dommage ça faisait
longtemps qu'on en avait besoin c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui en fait là l'espèce
de musique lancinante qui nous est
rabâché pour ne dire on a besoin de mine
parce qu'on a besoin d'économies et
parce que c'est le progrès
personnellement plus je m'intéresse aux
contenus métalliques des biens du
quotidien plus ça ne fait pas sens pour
moi en tous les cas il ya des endroits
où moi ça ne fait pas sens et les
priorités qui sont mises en termes
métallique pas je me retrouve moi
personnellement je me retrouve pas il
est possible que d'autres de mes
concitoyens ne s'y retrouve pas non plus
on parle jamais de l'or on parle
toujours du lithium du cobalt pourtant
on devrait s'y intéresser alors parce
qu'on y met lé vice ou de suez et puis
même quand warren buffett dit à partir
de 2015 que bon faut arrêter un peu avec
lorsque en fait c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça parce que c'est en
train de descendre etc les gens ils
continuent avec saison je continue avec
l'au revoir à thésauriser en se disant
on va mettre des lingots dans le dans la
salle à manger où dans le placard avec
l'argent friedman et alors que donc on
va prendre l'or l'or c'est un jamais
réussi à avoir des chiffres précis
j'avais contacté des économistes belge
qui m'avait informé en 2018 qui
pensaient qu'en termes de secteur
d'exploration donc par rapport aux
dépenses d'exploration lors à lui seul
toute substance confondues pourrait
représenter entre 50 et 75%
quand six textes à travailler sur une
cartographie qui s'appelle panoramique
cartographie des titres miniers qui
étaient en cours d'étude depuis 2012
on avait beaucoup porté sur l'or rosia
montana grèce c'est de l'or skouri à
côté des secours 20 secouristes et de
l'or
et du coup on s'est intéressés alors et
on s'est dit bon alors et puis bah
montagne d'un rien
or
on a une question du petit ardi va lui
donner sa question n'ont pas longtemps
donc la montagne d'or
en pleine forêt d'amazonie
[Musique]
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'elle
pense du sujet du positionnement de la
france dans les projets comme la
montagne d'or en guyane écologiquement
dévastateur vertueux ou en louer les
cours d'ouverture dans les cours d'eau
si je peux me permettre le projet de
montagne d'or prévoyez une cyanuration
est pas une amalgamation au mercure
alors c'est pas forcément mieux on
s'entend mais c'est important de le
presser parce que le ya bien du mercure
mais en fait qu'elle y aurait
remaniement de sols il ya des activités
anciennes français c'est pas l'heure pas
tout de suite dont deux hors plus
longtemps non c'est que en fait c'est
pas lié au traitement du minerai à
échelle industrielle on ne traite pas à
échelle industrielle nord avec du
mercure
voilà donc c'était pour ça que je
voulais préciser ok ce qu'est ce qu'on
en pense donc et donc je veux répond
après pour la gueule donc lors du coup
je me suis intéressé avec six textes on
a regardé sur les usages mais ça fait ça
fait peur alors c'est une économie saine
alors très bien
50 à 60% de leurs utilisé dans le monde
c'est la joaillerie et la bijouterie
art y ait encore des gens qui vous
m'expliquer que c'est extrêmement
symbole le symbole de l'alliance pour le
mariage je connais plein de gens autour
de moi sont des alliances en acier
surtout depuis qu'ils connaissent et ils
vont très très bien et il n'y a pas de
problème avec ça il ya plein de
bijouteries qui lui propose du recyclage
d'or
alors les gens disent oui mais quand
même qu'ils seront en compte ces
importants pingdingshan 60% enfin bon je
connais pas beaucoup de gens riches
heures dans mon entourage et pas
beaucoup de gens risquent je peux vous
assurer en fait que les gens que je
connais pas énormément d'or puisque 60%
des 3000 à 4000 tonnes produites par an
ça me paraissait beaucoup je trouvais ça
bizarre je me suis renseigné
ça vient principalement des indiens il
théorise beaucoup il théorise beaucoup
et au moins vous savez au moment du et
des mariages indiens au moment de mois
de mai il ya énormément de mariages
indiens et donc on paie c'est un moment
du mariage via le paiement des décotes
je crois qu'on parle donc on parle de ça
il ya une énorme un énorme choc
théorisation ashton à ce moment là parce
que du coup on va donner sur forme de
joyaux de statuettes etc
un tiers donc de ses 60% là c'est l'inde
déjà
alors donc un tiers de 60% ça fait donc
du coup un tiers de
2,06 à fait 18% aux quelques très beaux
arts après on a les fonds de pension
donc tout ce que vous disiez en fait
toutes les personnes qui investissent
alors
je suis pas économiste je comprends pas
tout en plus ces investisseurs quand il
parle j'ai du mal à comprendre je vais
être sincère mais j'ai lu des textes de
warren buffett et je me suis dit bon bah
lui il doit connaître son sujet
apparemment tout le monde me dit qu'il
connaît son sujet j'ai lu puis je me
suis mis il a pas l'air d'être trop à
pousser sur l'or et puis même en
l'occurrence il disait même l' inverse
non j'ai dit bon donc en gros il ya
alors là ça dépend des années ça dépend
si quels types de produits financiers
vous considérez puisqu'il ya notamment
par exemple des fonds de pension qui
peuvent investir il ya aussi il ya
plusieurs papiers alors voilà non bon
peu importe on va dire que l'on oscille
allez on va osciller entre 10 et 20% à
la louche par puis après vous avez lors
stockée lors des banque centrale l'or
qui est sous forme de lingots dans les
banques pas celui qui est dans les fonds
de pension et les produits financiers
vendus par sarkozy le fameux cui tout à
fait vous aviez suivi cette histoire
c'était fou il a vendu plein d'or de
l'enquêté de la banque mais oui j'ai pas
que ça à quitter fulham
cette histoire de rythme et j'ai
découvert ça sur le tas et donc est ce
qu'il m'a pas prévenue avant de le faire
il aurait pu m'appeler
le trésor de la france la ville toute
l'énergie que salon puis en plus
derrière le prix de l'or qui explosent
et ong a toujours dû voit pas toujours
du bon et du beaucoup oui c'était mais
c'était plus la moitié je prends ça
comme la rondelle ce tome savez en cours
du côté du podium
donc
donc là on est d'accord que si je résume
on appris de l'or qui était initialement
un gramme par tonne sous forme de
paillettes qui était dans un sous sol
on l'a sorti de terre on l'a broyé on
l'a traité 80 % de la production
mondiale est traité par cyanuration
je vous laisse imaginer comme on a un
gramme par tonne bah il faut traiter
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de quantité
donc ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
déchets et une fois qu'on a fini ça on
va en faire des lingots qui sont
minuscules minuscule on va les mettre
dans un sous sol c'est le principe de
l'an c'est pas un peu shader que cette
histoire mais c'est le principe de l'or
l'or au sens d'un trou pour remettre
dans un autre où apparemment aussi donc
ça savoure présent savez pourquoi mal
depuis la nuit des temps on fait ça à
mon art dit non parce que comme c'est
très chiant je suis désolé c'est un peu
plus comme ces traits ennuyons est très
énergivore de sortir le lors du sol
ça met de la valeur donc si je dois se
synthétiser ça trivialement la valeur
calorifique et stockés dans l'ordre et
c'est pour ça qu'on leur remet dans un
trou pour dire honda stocky l'or parce
que ces précieux c'est difficile et
cherchait donc ça vaut de la valeur
c'est le principe de l'ours et du
stockage de calories des temps alors
depuis la nuit des temps mais depuis en
étant il faudrait mettre ses fautes à
queue et les gens mettent leur fiche à
jour parce que quand on voit la
difficulté qu'ont à extraire une tonne
de cuivre
si bas qu'on stoppe maintenant des
laudes et
vous avez raison mais pas de la même
façon claire en tous les cas et surtout
pas dans des boxes central souffre
erreur de ma part donc voilà donc c'est
pour ça je te comprends tout à fait ce
que vous dites sur l'énergie nécessaire
et la valeur que ça mais le jour où vous
consultez sur lui
mais en l'occurrence le jour où je
décide du coup que le petit pois de
haute provence a énormément de valeur on
se met à les chercher à le vendre et à
le stocker dans des banques si vous
voulez c'est un choix pour ce qui se
passe non c'est un petit peu ce qui se
passe en fait c'est aussi un choix c'est
à dire que
au-delà de ça si vous voulez moi ce que
je vois là c'est que c'est un choix qui
a été fait par l'homme aussi certes
c'est un métal qui est extrêmement
stable excessivement résistant à la
corrosion et à l'oxydation il n'y a pas
de doute là dessus avec un très fort
taux de recyclabilité par ailleurs 1
c'est un des métaux qui se recyclent le
mieux c'est on peut le brûler là on a
quand même une petite perte au feu un
moment nombreux on a un petit peu de
matière qui s'envolent qui se sublimer
on a quand même toujours un très très
bon taux donc tu peux comprendre que ça
énormément de leur vessie c'est au
regard des efforts et l'énergie
nécessaires pour pouvoir obtenir une
quantité donnée alors certes par rapport
à l'or à la tonne oui je serais d'accord
de vous dire peut-être que à la tonne
oui parce que au final par an on compte
lui disais à mon produit que trois à
quatre mille tonnes par an mais beaucoup
beaucoup d'énergie pour obtenir peu mais
je m'intéresserais à ce moment là avec
autant d'ardeur par exemple au
platinoïdes le platine le palladium le
rhodium qui sont des métaux précieux qui
sont à peu près dans les mêmes sauts en
termes de concentration
et donc j'ai pas fini mon histoire sur
leur
éventuel coup je voulais juste finir sur
le dernier étage parce que tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit du coup on avait
50 % à peu près sûr le joaillerie bijoux
peu importe après on avait les fonds de
pension les produits financiers 10 à 15%
fonction des années après on avait la
bancarisation et nous manque en général
entre 5 et 10%
et c'est ça les usages industriels
j'ai dit non non pas quand même c'est
pas aussi peu alors je reverrai chimay
source quand même je dis bah non non ça
peut pas être aussi peu
puis en fait tout le monde était
d'accord parfois c'était 6 % parfois
c'était 8% puis parfois sept t3 et nîmes
et en l'occurrence chine au racing
blagues et après je me suis renseigné
sur la quantité d'or qu'on recycle et
chaque année comme on a dit que ça se
recycler très bien que c'est un ces
trois fois la quantité nécessaire pour
les usages industriels
de ce jour là j'ai plus du tout vus lors
de la même façon surtout quand je sais
que c'est là matières premières
minérales
qui est la première matières premières
minérales qui est chez métriques pardon
traités chimiquement c'est un milliard
de tonnes par an cyanure est pour ça
alors
à l'époque le ministre de
l'environnement de l'époque monsieur d
origine nous avait expliqué dans lors de
la session de l'assemblée nationale au
moment d'enregistrer sa comment bordeaux
j c'est quoi son prénom nom françois de
rugy françois de rugy oui il avait pris
la parole sur montagne d'or justement
est donc un moment il avait dit mais ce
qu'on ne vous dit pas c'est que la
raison pour laquelle on a développé la
cyanuration c'est parce qu'en fait si en
gros on fait pas ça eh ben on va
utiliser de du mercure et croyez moi le
mercure c'est bien pire
donc en gros il nie simon a développé la
cyanuration
l'intervention de ce ministre si on a
développé la cyanuration s'était
finalement pour résoudre les problèmes
de l'amalgamation
alors
[Rires]
la senyera sion elle a été développée en
1880 dans les années 1890 87 pour
certains dans le vide wetterstrand qu'il
a une très très grande province
aurifères en afrique du sud qui a été le
coeur de la production aurifère pendant
des années c'est le premier producteur
mondial d'or avant qu'il se fasse
dépasser par la chine ya quelques années
ils ont eu des patrons continue à la
porte soit
pas si je sais pas si c'est pour ça
qu'on les aide un bété pas tout montrer
qu est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que c'est un très grand pays minier un
très gros producteurs d'or très gros
pratique producteurs de platinoïdes très
gros producteur d'uranium de charbon
notamment et donc il y avait ceux où la
développer dans ce cadre-là en 1887
alors en fait on en 1887 autant vous
dire que dans huit facteurs semblent la
question de la protection
environnementale était relativement peu
présente dans le secteur industriel
minier aurifère donc ce n'est pas pour
ses pas pour cette raison qu'on l'a
développé c'est qu'en fait jusqu'en
1897 on était sur des gisements ou l'or
avait une certaine forme principalement
sous forme particulaire et c'est que
jusqu alors on arrivait même
particulière très fin on arriver à
l'obtenir il ya deux méthodes
l'amalgamation en ayant recours au
mercure ou la chloration
on a commencé à arriver à des nouveaux
gisements qui sont très exploité
aujourd'hui où l'or n'est plus sous
forme de paillettes il est sous forme
d'atomes
à l'intérieur de minéraux sulfurés
c'est ce qu'on appelle lors lié donc
l'or n'est pas libre il est lié alors
soit ça peut être il faut aussi des
tellurure d'or ou des choses comme ça
enfin il ya plein d'autres types de
relier mais en l'occurrence cette
heure-là la sellor de montagne d'or dire
que l'or il est certes sous forme de
petites paillettes très très fine en
dessous de 50 microns et c'est
à nouveau parce que vous avez une mamie
qui est une pépite aussi grosse que
celle que non pas quand même parce que
ça c est très impressionnant non c'est
pas du tout ça puis même une pépite qui
cros pépite c'est la taille d'un d'un
ongle c'est assez petit finalement mais
en fait leur ailier donc il est à
l'intérieur de ce qu'on appelle le
réseau cristallin ou qu'à l'intérieur du
minéral d'un par exemple sulfure de
cuivre ou un sulfureux d'arsenic et
la mine de salsigne vous aviez toute une
partie du gisement où en fait l'or
étaient à l'intérieur d'un sulfure de
fer et d'arsenic qu'on appelle l'art
seynod pyrite dans le cadre de montagne
d'or vous avez une partie de l'or qui se
trouve à l'intérieur de la chalcopyrite
donc un sulfure de fer et de cuivre
et donc comme mal à le mercure avait
atteint ses limites du coup on a fait
appel un produit un petit peu plus
convaincant pour l'or et donc du coup on
a fait appel et bien aussi à nyon en
1890 donc désolé pour monsieur de rugy
qui aurait dû vérifier ces fiches avant
mais on n'a absolument pas développé
pour des raisons environnementales
on l'a développée pour des raisons
pratiques lors on continue on voulait
continuer à aller chercher et on avait
besoin d'une substance chimique qui soit
suffisamment puissante pour pouvoir
l'extraire alors que lui il est a
vraiment sous forme très infinitésimale
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent dans
les mines d'or ne verront jamais d'or
parce que en fait y'a même pas de
paillettes on voit même pas de
paillettes moi j'ai visité plein de
mines d'or j'en ai jamais vu une
paillette d'or si trop petit en fait
c'est à l'état d'atomes ou c'est l'état
me voyez quand je disais 50 microns
voyait 50 microns c'est tout petit c'est
tout petit petit chou oui
vraiment tout petit donc je voulais
juste mal à finir de répondre sur
montagne d'or c'est le seul projet miné
contre lesquels six textes s'est
positionné
donc c'était environ tellement c'était
aberrant tellement c'était intenable en
fête
typiquement et alors il ya plusieurs
versions du projet à ce jour il ya
toujours pas eu d'étude d'impact 1
pourquoi son but est que ce genre de
considérations bah oui j'entends mais on
n'a toujours pas eu d'étude d'impact
c'est le seul projet contre lequel si ce
texte est opposée effectivement
tellement c'était aberrant de vouloir
extraire de l'or donc ans gagnera sion
dans une zone de la guyane je sais pas
si boxer saluer mais j'y suis allé à
plusieurs reprises quand il pleut il
pleut et mais trinh-duc et quand il joue
il fut chaud
et de 2,6 m hind higuain qui à l'époque
alors on avait essayé de faire les
calculs on était autour de 300 millions
de mètres cubes mais on a eu du mal à
faire les calculs ce que c'est pas si
simple en fait de calculer le volume des
déchets mini qu'on pourrait avoir
on faisait les calculs et on a dit là
dessus il va falloir rajouter 6 mètres
d'eau par an
ça va bien se passer
ça c'est juste un détail autre détail
que qui n'avait pas été évoquée lors des
première présentation du projet c'est
que c'était une des premières fois en
guyane alors nonobstant certains projets
qui existent aujourd'hui qui commence à
rentrer dans cette zone on va commencer
à rentrer en profondeur la guyane en
guyane française il n'y a aucun site
mines et industriels à très grande
échelle il ya des sites miniers comme à
yahoo par exemple ou d'autres cas des
sites miniers qui sont échelle on va
ailleurs semi-industrielle juste pas si
on autorise à utiliser ce piège et il ya
effectivement en plus de l'exploitation
légale qui et qui est présente qui est
sous forme du commun soir on
alluvionnaires soit alluvionnaires et
primaire vous avez à peu près dix mille
karim perros qui produisent à peu près
les fonctions des statistiques
douanières
sur 10 tonnes d'or produites je crois
que ces deux tonnes d'or produites ou 10
tonnes enfin c'est très grande majorité
de la production
n'est pas référencé dans les points deux
copains de l'est si vous voulez les
extras en lien avec les exploitations
légal très grande majorité donc
effectivement vous avez une activité
légale qui est alluvionnaires qui
souvent en fait s'est déclaré sous forme
de ce qu'on appelle une autorisation
d'exploiter une ax donc ça c'est dans le
cadre de cours d'eau vous avez un
système de barran que souvent c'est du
gravimétrique certainement des gens qui
ont vu ça bref vous avez effectivement
l'illégal
c'est à la marge en ça c'est pas la
marche en termes de quantité c'est à la
marge en terme de fonctionnement et de
capacité d'action du point de vue de
l'ingénieur minier et puis après vous
avez là mes gamines qui n'existe pas
pour l'instant et quand visez vous avez
des sites qui ont commencé en fait à
sortir de la zone d'épaisseur et qui ont
commencé à rentrer en profondeur entrer
dans la zone plus en revanche roche en
dur si vous voulez nous schématiquement
et quand on fait ça on en rencontre
plein de minéraux parce que comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure un gisement
de cliffs est pas du cuivre est là où je
crois assez du cuivre du molybdène du
zinc du plomb est donc un point de
minéraux de l'uranium
pour certains sites mais pas tous et à
ses parrains copuler l'uranium est un
conte produits frais quand par exemple
des mines d'or ça c'est un coproduit
qu'on connaît c'est vrai que sur le
cuivre à ma connaissance s'est pas
encore produit aussi fréquents voilà et
donc du coup tout ça pour dire que bah
on s'est rendu compte en guyane que plus
on commençait à aller en profondeur et
plus on arrivait à
désoxydation de l'étau enfin de pardon
de minéraux qui était à l'origine du
fameux pour ceux qui connaissent
traînage minier acide dire qu'en fait on
est en train de rentrer dans une branche
qui a été préservé des précipitations et
de l'oxydation jusqu alors qui contient
beaucoup de sulfures opus sulfures plus
oxygène et ben ça fait de l'acide et
vous pouvez prendre le problème par un
sens par un autre ce sera toujours non
donc toutes ces considérations là
au départ consiste ex travaillé sur le
projet de montagne d'or c'est parce que
c'est des gens c'est au tout début 2016
et c'est les gens nous ont contactés
1,10 en charge des associations qui
connaissent ces questions milliards ce
qu'on reçoit des documents et on
comprend pas est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer les documents qu'on a commencé
là dessus on soigne et ben voilà on a
compris ça on a compris s'appuient de
plus en plus on monte en compétences et
puis à un moment donné nous aussi à
force de travailler pour essayer de
comprendre le projet puis décrypter
certains enjeux l'étude de faisabilité
en anglais sur un projet mise quelque
chose d'assez difficile à beaucoup
terminologie technique difficilement
accès est en fait en faisant ce travail
là on s'est rendu compte de l'ampleur du
prochain on a dit non non non non non
pas ça mais il ya surtout et c'est que
je reviens à votre histoire avec ce
monsieur
qui qui souhaitaient en fait investir
dans la mine par rapport à des enjeux
économiques et ont surtout pas pour de
l'or pas pour ça pour d'autres
substances que l'entente n'est pas pour
l'or et
aussi par rapport à cet enjeu de
transition donc j'ai évoqué la question
donc deux fois plus d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qu'un véhicule électrique
qu'un véhicule thermique à ce titre je
vous encourage vraiment à consulter une
enquête en trois volets qui a été
réalisé par soli et célia izoird un
reporter qui est extrêmement bien fait
qui parle justement ces questions de
véhicules électriques c'est vraiment
très très bien fait c'est une enquête
d'investigation de long terme moi j'ai
utilisé beaucoup de rapports qu'elle
mentionne notamment le fameux rapport de
l'agencé européenne de l'environnement
dans lequel j'ai trouvé ce j'ai retrouvé
ces chiffres de hanau x 200 x etc
et donc voilà et on a parlé du coût de
la question de la transition des
véhicules électriques mais je voulais
vous donner un exemple qui pour moi est
un petit peu le même enjeu que le
véhicule électrique celle en poule
le petit objet banal de notre quotidien
auquel on ne pense pas alors qu'il est
toujours là qui nous permet d'éclairer
nos pièces et c'est donc pendant très
longtemps vous avez pas fait ce pas
quand vous étiez enfant vous admirez
l'incandescence du filament de tungstène
qui était dans l' en poule non vous
faisiez passage était prédisposé à l'or
et du coup je regardais ça je trouve ça
merveilleux et puis un jour on nous a
dit la lampe à incandescence ça consomme
trop on va pince et aux lampes fluo
compactes
qui n'est pas de radiations tout ça cc
c'est celle là alors il y en a deux
celle qui aimait pas de radiations
c'est une bouteille adacore la lumière
est une radiation c'est sarah bombe
d'accord est pardon pardon
c'est vous savez c'est celle qui ont le
vert blanc opaque et qui sont en ce que
poussière quand on est gosse
il ya un petit problème avec les pouces
et justement parlons-en et donc ça fait
des tortillons comme ça où des
tortillons comme ça donc ça c'est les
ampoules fluocompactes et du coup moi je
me suis intéressé par ce qu'on m'a dit
c'est une ampoule verte mais vraiment
celle ampoules écolos c'est une énorme
économie d'énergie c'est que ça je vais
faire le parallèle avec le lan poulets
élevés qui laissait qui vous verrez en
fait c'est exactement la même histoire
qu'on raconte à chaque fois non du coup
je dis bon allez on va étudier les
ampoules ça c'est un sujet qui
m'intéresse donc je commence à essayer
de regarder un peu la composition d'une
ampoule je suis pas dans l'éclairage pas
lectrices je peins électricité c'est de
comprendre qui je vois en fait que du
coup une ampoule fluocompacte c'est un
verre qui est recouvert d'une poudre qui
contient des matières luminophores donc
en l'occurrence c'est souvent des terres
rares type gadolinium cérium aux autres
qui sont à l'intérieur de matrice à base
de magnésium à base de baryum à base
d'oxydé d'yttrium si mes souvenirs sont
bons donc voilà vous avez ça et à
l'intérieur ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va exciter en fait on ya une
vapeur de mercure et d'argon on m'a
excité cette vapeur et le lait
luminophores si vous voulez parmi
lesquels ils étaient rares vont émettre
et vous allez obtenir un gain
substantiel d'éclairage souvenons nous
qu'une lampe à incandescence a une durée
de vie d'à peu près 1000 heures alors
qu'une lampe fluocompacte et une de
ravenhill de 8000 heures et ne parlons
même pas des lettres qui peut monter
jusqu'à 40 ou 50 miller mais oui à
l'ancien mais c'est incroyable c'est la
honte et cetera disons 99
par lodsys
et donc après je me suis aussi renseigné
sur les led parce que les led quand vous
regardez des leds tiens d'ailleurs fait
certain que peu importe à vis du 8
certain que ce thème je vous assure
c'est les dernières ampoules attaque
stand bien d'accord et du coup on fait
donc on se retrouva donc à regarder les
led et alors là les led on est sûr
principalement ses bases de gallium donc
c'est du nitrure de gallium et d'arsenic
s'appelle du fausse fourrure de gallium
et encore quatre grandes technologies à
base de canne et qui touche aussi
bah oui et or justement le problème
c'est que c'est extrêmement compliqué à
recycler et
boulot alors pour les fluocompactes moi
j'ai eu une gélule une étude de 2012
j'ai du mal à trouver des publications
scientifiques sur les ampoules pas ce
que vous cherchez pas ainsi
donc ce les ampoules on est à plus de 20
métaux à l'intérieur là tant au niveau
du recyclage
effectivement c'est assez compliqué
voire parfois on recycle pas durcir
compile ont pilé on stocke en souterrain
quoi ont pilé alors alors il ya eu des
projets notamment de récupération
terreur qui avaient été portées pour
ceux qui connaissent dans la région de
la rochelle part seul mais qu'on était
du coup malheureusement abandonné c'est
un projet qui a acquis s'est poursuivie
donc il y avait quand même des
initiatives etc j'arrive pas avoir de
statistiques ça j'arrive pas vous donner
aujourd'hui de chiffres sur combien en
quantité on recycle de fluo compactes et
de l'aisne par contre ce que je peux
dire c'est que les auteurs de 2012 que
j'ai consultés me disent on tue des
chercheurs qu'on fait une étude sur
fluocompactes et l'aide le dise le fluo
compactes on monte jusqu'à 26 fois plus
d'impact qu'une lampe à incandescence
et on est entre deux à cinq fois plus
d'impact en fonction de ce qu'on
considère sur une led
résumons-nous
pour pouvoir augmenter la durée
d'éclairage et la diminution énergétique
en fait ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
fait du dopage métallique ni plus ni
moins et on a créé des déchets qui alors
intéressant j'ai pas si vous savez mais
les ampoules à incandescence
on pouvait les mettre dans la poubelle
ou dans une poubelle en fait avant on
pouvait pas ce que c'est que du vert et
du lynx n est pas considéré comme un
produit dangereux les nouvelles ampoules
le sont elles sont considérés comme
produits dangereux autre ironie de
l'histoire combien de fois nous hâtons
rabâcher les oreilles avec le
thermomètre en mercure il faut faire
très très attention et ne surtout
surtout pas le casser je connais plein
de gens qu'on cassait des ampoules
fluocompactes 1 ça arrive ça arrive à
plein de gens bien pleins de poussière
ça fait plein de poussière blanche à
aimer énormément de la peur de mercure
si le sujet vous intéresse je vous
encourage vivement à lire la
bibliographie canadienne des services de
santé canadien qui alerte sur deux
choses la santé la santé des habitants
suite à un bris de fluo compactes les
émissions de vapeurs de mercure
mais aussi la question de la santé des
gens qui sont dans les points de
collecte les points de récupération et
les centres de recyclage qui eux sont
soumis dire qu'on met en plus en danger
des gens qui travaillent dans ces usines
là en toute connaissance de cause
puisqu'on le sait alors on nous dit oui
non mais ne vous inquiétez pas ouais on
sait qu'on a des pistes siècle le flot
compact mais de plus en plus c'est la
led qui va prendre la suite donc on
rappelle un détour d'arséniure 20 titres
sûrs arsenic gallium
alors oui je veux bien que l'on mette
des led alors je ne parle même pas
du fait qu'on ait une dispense et normes
d'éclairage de partout pour éclairer ce
dont on n'a pas besoin mais admettons on
va encore me dire que
mais admettons c'est pas grave mais
indépendamment de cela en fait c'est
pour vous donner un exemple pour venir
l'an poule verte écolo qu'on vous vend
là la fluocompacte mais c'est en fait
c'est une blague c'est comme le vc c'est
le véhicule électrique du véhicule
thermique c'est la fluocompacte du de
l'ampoulé à incandescence affinera le
taxage que fait l'avocat du diable oui
c'est pas possible
ou d'accord le gouvernement ministre de
l'écologie seraient jamais laisser faire
ça c'est forcément que c'est plus vert
et que sa console wii à paris ça ça
sauve les bébés phoques sur la je
comprends que vous ayez un vrai succès
d'ebay fonctionner on peut en parler
spécifiquement bien que j'ai pas de
compétences spécifiques sur les phoques
mais non mais j'entends bien ce que vous
dites mais déjà quand l'interdiction fin
2012 début 2013 soit les ampoules à
incandescence elle a été mise en vigueur
en europe
et oui c'est c'est d'un point c'est une
directive européenne du coup
d'interdictions des emplois d'ici fin
2012 début d'une phrase moi je me
souviens à peine déjà et ben moi j'ai
pas le souvenir qui est une mobilisation
massive pour dire peut-être qu'on peut
garder tranquille des ampoules
classiques avec du verre un filament de
tungstène est un petit peu d'aluminium
de chrome de faire un petit peu de
manganèse au niveau du culot ça suffit
bien et on le recycle et ça marche très
bien et on vous dit oui mais on fait une
économie sur le temps où mais les métaux
en fait si vous voulez c'est ça c'est
que les gens ont une vision de
l'économie d'énergie sur une vision mais
c'est extrêmement court termiste alors
en général c'est sur leur usage lire le
nom en fonction du nombre de colis mode
que je vais parcourir ou en fonction du
nombre de fois que je vais utiliser
moelle en poule par exemple il s'est
extrêmement court termiste comme vision
des choses c'est des tirs c'est dire si
vous voulez comprendre l'impact
écologique grain dispositif il faut tout
prendre et ça c'est quelque chose que je
souhaite vraiment sur lequel je souhaite
insister c'est à six textes on est
vraiment on est vraiment fâché du fait
que toutes les considérations de ce que
c'est que un produit impact
environnemental s'est basé sur les
impacts sur les gaz à effet de serre
vous êtes écologiquement responsable
parce que vous émettez pas beaucoup de
gaz à effet serre et vous êtes
écologiquement irresponsable parce que
vous en et mettez beaucoup mais diable
il ya bien d'autres considérations à
prendre en compte
la question du fait qu' on enlève des
cinq ans on détruise des zones protégées
que l'on tolu massivement des cours
d'eau et des nappes d'eau sert des
masses d'eau qu'elles soient
souterraines ou en surface consté
release des terres qu'on stérilise des
zones qui peuvent ni même plus l'aide
des zones agricoles ce sont des réalités
qu'il faut prendre en compte et
aujourd'hui on ne le quantifie pas ça on
le quantifier extrêmement bas alors
effectivement à me parler encore de
l'équivalent timone et puis enfin je
vous le dis aujourd'hui on quantifie
très mal on a beaucoup d'elle même sur à
l'échelle du site minier on n'y arrive
pas quand aujourd'hui on demande aux
gens sur tel site minier est ce que vous
avez une idée de
l'emprise en masse mon surface de la
contamination des eaux liée au site des
journées soit plus ou moins km
on va aborder d'autres sujets est ce que
vous êtes intéressé sur l'exploitation
minière spatiale le fait de mettre en
orbite un astéroïde autour de la terre
et de gentiment le découper en petits
morceaux pour faire de l'exploitation
minière spatiale c'est bien c'est pas
bien
c'est pour nous donner de l'espoir et
ensuite après l'exploitation minière
spatiale on passera sur la question de
dodo politique la réalité des politiques
le coup du côté court termiste des
politiques je vous laisse la parole sur
l'espace
on a suivi la question de l'espace qui
n'est même pas démarré il ya simplement
des projets qui sont en cours mais il
n'y a pas encore eu des vraies
exploration s'il n'y a pas encore eu
d'échantillonnage massif sur des
astéroïdes donc on est au tout début
vous souvenez de l'histoire que je vous
racontais sur les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires qui alimentent en
extrait les sites miniers qui produisent
des métaux
et ben
en fait moi je vais me pose enfin le
l'aérospatiale on s'est très bourmaud en
métaux
et pas qu'au niveau des dispositifs qui
sont envoyées dans l'espace
c'est aussi il ya toutes les plateformes
de décollage et machin tous les trucs y
moi je ne suis pas ingénieur en
aérospatial dont je m'arrêterai là pour
les considérations et c'est un sujet que
j'ai envie d'approfondir c'est à dire
les consommations métallique du secteur
de l'aérospatiale s'il y en a deux qui
passe souvent sous les radars c'est
l'aérospatiale en termes de demande
métallique et le secteur de la défense
ces deux secteurs là il passe souvent
sous les radars défoncé norman
jeunesse est
[Rires]
donc en fait déjà je m'interroge sur
l'énergie vous voit vous savez ce qu'on
dit par exemple sur les barils de
pétrole le plus le temps avance et plus
il faut de barils de pétrole pour
extraire un baril de pétrole et c'est
cette histoire là
du coup moi je
sans vouloir faire un parallèle honteux
il ya quand même une forme de
similarités quand on dit plus le temps
avance et plus on met de l'énergie pour
aller chercher une quantité de métal et
je ne m'y connais pas en aérospatiale
donc je pourrais pas vous en dire plus
dans tous les cas ce que je sais c'est
que ses aînés fins et très consommateur
de métaux et que je me dise il faut ce
qui serait quand même assez ironique ce
qu'on arrive à envoyer dans l'espace
pour faire des tests du travail de
l'exploration et l'exploitation plus de
métal que ce qu'on récupère sincèrement
je trouve ça sera quand même assez drôle
ça c'est pour la partie exploitation
spatiale mais si on peut aussi évoquer
rapidement une autre frontière
extractives et un peu du même genre vous
voyez peut-être celle à laquelle je
pense le drogue les fonds marins à
l'épaule est plus dodue le public voit
la
baisse des dons de requins
qui vous a dit que vous ramassez les
donnerai qu'un cd dodu le polymétallique
c'est pas des dents de requins ont des
petites places et des courses et des
concrétions je sais pas si c'est des
dindes recarrossée des concrétions qui
se sont formés dans des zones de fond
m'annonçant vous avez les nodules
polymétalliques vous avez les encres
hautement probable qu'ils faire et vous
avez aussi les dépôts hydrothermaux au
niveau des ce qu'on appelle les fumeurs
noirs vous savez au niveau notamment des
doors et des écosystèmes coup de
kolingba alors dans les trois cas
d'ailleurs dans les trois cas et bah
pour moi en fait c'est assez
symptomatique c'est à dire que ce que si
ce texte fait comme travail depuis des
années c'est de dire il ya une activité
minière qui est l'indispensable à bien
des égards qui mais qui a des impacts
graves qui n'arrive pas à maîtriser bon
nombre de ses impacts et il va falloir
agir et trouver le moyen à la fois de
réduire la demande mais aussi de réduire
les impacts
et en parallèle vous avez donc une un
secteur qui est quand même connu au
regard de toutes les statistiques
majeures que je vous donne c'est le
premier en cl premier en savent ainsi
quand même le mauvais élève quoi en plus
de tout ça on vous dit bon on n'y arrive
pas sur la terre c'est pas grave on va
en mer et puis pas n'importe où on
allait les écologistes y vos oiseaux
parce qu'il commence à voir le pied bas
et si je suis par
un kevin keith a fait une surveillance
d'un travail d'exploration sur une
petite semaine il ya donc vous inquiétez
pas ils sont là
mais sur la kalachnikov
mais mais en fait enfin comment est ce
que vous voulez accorder du crédit à
quelqu'un qui j'ai pas résolus mais
problème sur terre où là où c'est quand
même assez simple et on va aller et pas
n'importe où alors ok les nodules
polymétalliques ça commence à 800 m mais
on arrive à plusieurs milliers de mètres
de profondeur pour les autres ce qui est
quand même assez hallucinant moi je ne
connaissais pas du tout ce monde est
assis ce texte on travaille de plus en
plus de six ans nous a demandé de
dévaluer la question on a lu sans vous
mentir 1
2 ou 300 publications scientifiques sur
ce sujet pour essayer de comprendre
quelles étaient les techniques les
impacts qu'est ce qui se passait en fait
mais on a dit mais c'est pas possible il
ya 300 chercheurs ou plus qu on écrit
des papiers puis personnes
les uns ne les a écoutés c'est pas
possible vous avez des dizaines et des
dizaines de chercheurs qui vous disent
mais en fait non c'est complètement
aberrant ce sont des milieux qui sont
plus complètement protéger protéger de
la lumière
protéger
du bruit ces sont des milieux où il est
très noir fait boire y a pas de lumière
il n'y a pas de wii ea ont dit oui non
mais vous inquiétez pas valérie avec des
we move de operated vehicle vallée
machin donc les les espèces et des trucs
avec des bouts de l'opi sud oui voilà et
vous savez que du coup tout le monde
croit que c'est des robots dans l'abside
et puis moi je là vous faites fort
excité de petite taille et annonce un
gros temps qui lie ces normes en fait
j'avais pas du tout j'en ai un peu
envoyez quand j'ai commencé à me
renseigner sur le sujet je pensais que
c'était un peu petit et en fait du coup
je me renseigne sur le projet nautilus
qu'est le projet le plus abouti au large
de la papouasie nouvelle guinée qui a
été arrêté suite à un moratoire pris par
le gouvernement est en fait il ya deux
appareils un pour préparer la zone et un
pour réaliser l'exploit l'extraction va
dire recense et aux sangsues et le le
les deux appareils font craindre un des
deux qui fait deux cent cinq tonnes
sans temps qu'un véhicule individuel
moyen c'est à peu près 2 tonnes 1.5 à 2
tonnes 5 je veux pas de problème avec
les gens qui ont des véhicules plus gros
ça ne me regarde pas je dis juste la
moyenne on nous promet redon
j'en ai une nouvelle guider et donc du
coup vous êtes 100 fois plus gros
qu'hervé que 200 tonnes cédées ordre de
grandeur que je connaisse et les gros
tombereaux qui monte jusqu'à 450 tonnes
à vide ces des tombereaux sont à peu
près 200 tonnes c'est des tombereaux de
100 tonnes c'est déjà énorme maison dé
s'être convenons avatar d un peu plus
petits c'est ça le ton bruce espèce de
grosse ben oui un camion avec une toute
petite entrée nous très grosses bennes
et vous avez des très très grosses roues
qui font jusqu'à ce 4 mètres de haut qui
ont pu jouer les gamins avec un robot
del rey dû aller préparer un joli petit
véhicule comme ça la salle tombereaux
j'ai étudié la mine de cresson peu
importe ses mines d'or il ya des
véhicules comme ça on va céder 200
tonnes 450 tonnes charge plein bon vous
dites 200 tonnes c'est gros c'est gros
malins et plus et c'est que le début il
est jeune il n'a fric
j'ai vraiment du mal parce que je n'ai
vraiment lu des dizaines et des dizaines
de publications scientifiques les
fautifs c'est pour ça que c'est risible
mais en fait vous dites que vous avez lu
autant de publication et que c'est des
gens qui vous disent ne tient aucun
problème avec l'exploration des fonds
marins en chimie l'once d'or compte rond
et vous dites mais est est-ce qu'on peut
prendre du recul se dire qu'on va
faire descendre deux cents tonnes de
métal aller même si je me mets au niveau
uniquement une profondeur des nodules
polymétalliques à les 1500 mètres de
profondeur déjà j'aimerais bien savoir
quelle est la grue qui va aller chercher
les 200 tonnes à 1500 mètres de
profondeur quand on aura fini
d'exploiter
mais admettons et ensuite deux audio vos
organes où vous allez mettre 200 tonnes
dans un environnement qui ne connaît
aucune perturbation aucun panache aucune
lumière
prétendre qu'il n'y aura pas de problème
enfin c'est une malhonnêteté compte tenu
à les voir les problèmes donc ya pas de
problème si vous voulez vous alors on
les verra pas et c'est intéressant
justement que vous en parliez parce que
souvent effectivement
on considère la faune benthique de façon
très isolés je ne suis pas écologue donc
je voulais je ne vous parle sont pas
beaux
justement moi j'aimais avoue être à
temps vous avez tort de dire ça je ne
connaissais rien la faune benthique j'ai
découvert mais c'est un monde
merveilleux en plus souvent ils sont
luminescents vous devriez voir ce
vendredi c'est ça c'est le commandant
cousteau et qu'une robe de chambre
c'est super beau je refuse que vous
disais que ces animaux sans moi j'ai
déjà n'y a pas de match le nom mais
vivait à peut-être été modifié cette
naissance mais de la foudre de lipper
profonde ans et ses manies six voix cnic
de chasse c'est absolument magnifique
le poulpe le poulpe comment il s'appelle
ce fameux poulpe qui se déploie qui
changent de couleur
connaît pas les seuls et je ne sais pas
le tout ce que j'ai vu c'est qu'on m'a
montré des photos de la faune benthique
plus ou moins luminescentes et là j'ai
trouvé ça merveilleux et en fait
justement c'est intéressant parce que
typiquement ce qu'on a lu et ce qu'on a
expliqué parce que j'ai pris contact
aussi avec des personnes qui étaient
spécialisés sur ces questions c'est que
en fait ces compartiments bazzo donc on
est au dessus de la en dessous de la
zone pélagiques dans laquelle la soule
ont plutôt les poissons qui eux sont
plus qu'ils sont pas au fond quoi ils
vont bouger et c'est nous elles sont
parties comment jusqu'à 400 m ah bah non
la faune benthique si votre fond de
l'eau il est allumette pour le plus
logique pour la paix la gigue en fête
c'est la colonne d'eau qui surplombe la
zone 20 tic donc c'est au dessus de la
zone indique sans que la faune benthique
en tant que tel en général on considère
que c'est celle qui ne se mouche enfin
quelqu'un qui ne se déplace pas c'est ce
qui va rester au fond en fait et après
vous avez la faune pélagiques et la
faune de la colonne d'eau puis après ça
dépend de votre plateau continental de
vaud profondeur et c'est en fait cette
faune là elle communique contrairement à
ce qu'on peut croire il ya aussi la
génération 2
de ce qu'on appelle alors attendez en
fait c'est l'équivalent de la
photosynthèse non au fond des mers quoi
le terme
je m'échappe
c'est un équivalent si vous voulez de
production primaire végétal mais souvent
fait à des zones qui sont très profondes
en fait du soufre oui voilà de mémoire
ben voilà donc vous avez des mécanismes
en fait qui
sont extrêmement présents et qui ne
concerne pas uniquement que le fond
marin et d'autan que s'agissant des
fonds marins mais y compris des fonds
marins extrêmement profond on dispose
déjà d'un retour d'expérience qui n'est
pas complètement équivalent mais qui est
comparable dans le domaine minier c'est
le déversement de résidus miniers
actuellement on procède dans plusieurs
sites dans le monde en particulier en
norvège à du déversement de résidus
miniers directement dans les masses
d'eau donc en cours d'eau en fjord où
dans les milieux marins et de plus en
plus on se dirige vers ce qu'on appelle
le deep sea disposons donc là cette fois
ci c'est plus le dixie mining c'est le
type ci dispose hall c'est à dire qu'on
va opposer entreposés des déchets
miniers à des profondeurs élevé donc ça
peut même aller jusqu'à au delà de 1000
m si vous avez la topographie marine qui
vous le permet et les retours
d'expériences visuelles en voiture puis
mis là on dépose des résidus miniers et
on manie pas enfanter pas une zone
d'exploitation dans le sens on remanie
pas insolent présent c'est que c'est un
certain j'entends jean je comprends bien
le principe mais dans les faits
globalement les panaches de sédiments
c'est les mêmes un la toxicité des
métaux et des métallos ide qui sont
constitutifs de ces matériaux c'est les
mêmes profondeur c'est les mêmes voient
donc c'est tous ces phénomènes là du
coup qui ont déjà été alors bien sûr
c'est qu'un équivalent mais c'est
important d'avoir en tête ce parallèle
sans pour autant faire un systématisme
on s'entend que ce ne sont pas les mêmes
façons de traiter les fonds marins tous
les cas dans les deux cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'on les maltraite les
fonds marins déposer des résidus min en
fond marin c'est catastrophique
exploiter des fonds marins c'est
catastrophique alors une fois
une fois dit ça si vous voulez surtout
que quand on regarde la composition des
métaux et qu'on se rend compte que
finalement dans les nodules
polymétalliques et a ni plus ni moins
que les mêmes métaux que dont on parle
tout le temps
c'est le cuivre le plomb le zinc le
manganèse le cobalt et cetera meilleure
concentration
oui mais dans les meilleurs
concentration mais jean sioui je me
rends bien compte qu'il ya de forts taux
de concentration mais comme dans le
monde minier la fonte ya pas que la
concentration il ya la concentration et
puis à la quantité et ensuite c'est la
capacité que vous vous avez à récupérer
ça
aujourd'hui sur dépannage de sédiments
que l'on peut voir par exemple encore
une fois je me base sur le retour
d'expérience comme le dit si manning
n'existe pas je me base sur un retour
d'expérience plutôt liée au dépôt de
déchets miniers en mer quand vous avez
au niveau des conduite d'amenée des
déchets miniers donc ce qui correspond
au mot normal on a ce qu'on va remonter
1 dans l'autre cas vous avez des fuites
qui sommes qui peuvent se produire ça
arrive assez souvent au niveau des
conduite d'amenée et on a des par
exemple des fuites en fait de déchets
miniers qui vont allez on va dire sur
des profondeurs d'eau tour de 200 à 300
mètres s'est pas complètement incohérent
mais que les hypothèses qu'on aura une
exploitation de nodules polymétalliques
mille mètres de profondeur on a une
fuite à 300 m
ça paraît cohérent on pourrait avoir ce
cas là quand vous voyez les dégâts
majeurs que ça occasionne d'abord sur la
faune et ensuite sur les gens quand on a
le malheur de se trouver dans des zones
qui sont soit habité alors revenir là
vous inquiétez pas à la dorsale ou
clipperton tout ça y'a personne oui soit
habité soient utilisés vous n'êtes pas
seuls à utiliser ces eaux il ya aussi
les pêcheurs il ya d'abord la nature et
ensuite les pêcheurs quand vous voyez
les impacts encore une fois en
comparaison avec ce qu'on fait en termes
de dépôt de résidus min en font mal
quand vous lisez tout cette biographie
que vous prenez le temps de regarder
personne ne peut considérer qu'un
bien-fondé quelconque à vouloir
envisager une exploration et
exploitation des fonds marins personnes
faut prendre le temps faut étudier faut
écouter les gens mais il ya beaucoup
plus de gens qui sont défavorables que
favorable dans ces cas là il faudrait
peut-être s'interroger sur les raisons
pour lesquelles tout le monde est
d'accord sur ce sujet
c'est une catastrophe environnementale
qui est prévisible et quoi qu'en dise je
suis très conscient des discours récents
qui ont été faits notamment dans le
cadre du plan de relance 2030 dans
lequel il a été fait mention du fait
qu'on souhaitait relancer l'exploration
minière mais qu'il ne s'agissait pas
d'exploration pour l'exploitation
minière mais bien d'exploration pour
mieux comprendre la faune et la flore de
ces milieux là et que date dans plus à
nous apporterait un certain nombre
d'informations scientifiques et ses
terrains et pour en avoir aussi parlé
avec des chercheurs qui travaillent qui
sont plutôt
spécialisés non ces écosystèmes là
la raison pour laquelle on connaît mal
c'est mieux c'est parce que c'est
difficile de faire la recherche dans ses
fonds marins
pour des raisons financières mais aussi
pour des raisons de vous allez observer
quelque chose
par exemple comment je vous donne cet
exemple du tout le monde tel qu'on
devait tu le comprends comment observer
un animal alors que vous pouvez pas ou
très peu faiblement l'éclairer parce
qu'il n'a pas du tout l'habitude de la
lumière ou comment vous faites venir des
engins avec du bruit alors qu'il n'a pas
du tout l'habitude du bruit donc il ya
aussi une difficulté dans l'exploration
des fonds marins et notamment de la
faune parce que ce sont des habitats qui
sont extrêmement épargné et qui sont
difficiles à étudier si on veut les
étudier tout en les protégeant g7
souvenir incroyable au niveau de la zone
de clipperton mais moi quand j'ai lu ça
mais j'ai dit mais c'est pas possible
que ça existe au niveau de la dorsale de
clipperton en fait il ya des des petites
machines pour qu'on s'appelle qui ont
des phares et qui surveille en fait la
zone de dorsal il ya des chercheurs en
2015 qui ont démontré que la simple
observation faisait ça vous observez une
dorsale il faut éclairer valeriano voir
sinon pour filmer pour prendre des
photos il faut éclairer las le simple
fait qu'on mette de la lumière juste
pour surveiller un sacré des lésions
rétiniennes sûr pour les crevettes qui
habitait dans la zone
rien que ça j'ai pas ramené 1
un tombereau déguisée de 200 tonnes au
fond
donc il ya aussi une difficulté dans
l'exploration c'est que
vous avez le droit de vous avez le droit
de dénigrer les fonds marins c'est votre
problème c'est pas mon cas donc il a
décroché que deux bornes sont prêts coup
de flash bon ben voilà c'est parce que
les fonds marins est bien quand je vous
disais c'est en lien avec les autres
compartiments marrant que par ce qu'on
appelle déjà l'impression alors c'est
assez drôle qu on s'insurge avec autant
de surprises sur le continent de
plastique et que ça nous pose aucun
problème dalé quelques kilomètres en
dessous pour aller bousiller les fonds
marins excusez moi de l'expression mais
en l'occurrence quand vous mettez 1 200
tonnes sur une zone hydrothermales pour
pouvoir exploiter de l'en-but qu'un seul
j'ai des doutes j'étais sérieux doutes
sur moi donc et a aussi cet enjeu là et
vous voulez après parler de politique
mais bon les politiques qui sont eux
deux qui sont conscients ou inconscients
vous les envoyer dans l'espace
chacun pourquoi vous voulez pourquoi
voulez vous que je gastriques et métal
pour faire ça
j'ai des contacts avec eux ou très peu
enfin les politiques ça dépend mr
d'écolo les mini très très peu trop très
très peu un astre est le qui s'offrit 6
ils savent qu'on existe zolpan vous en
contre lui en veux non non je pense pas
il ya aussi le fait que si ce texte est
beaucoup plus un travail de l'expertisé
de l'évaluation et que c'est vrai qu'on
est beaucoup moins dans les champs
d'expertisé de plaidoyer de questions
juridiques donc c'est aussi peut-être
qui nous éloignent
alors en main propre nom par contre
quand on les publie bah ils vont vouloir
mettre des coloriages ils comprennent et
question internet quel métal pour
remplacer le cuivre dans le conducteur
électrique
ça va être très compliqué ça va être
très très compliqué c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle beaucoup de gens
s'inquiètent aujourd'hui plus pour le
cuivre par exemple que pour le cobalt
parce que le cuivre en termes de
substitution ça va être compliqué et
aussi parce que vous avez beaucoup d'
usage si vous voulez concurrents en fait
ah ça c'est important oui les usages
concurrents oui ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que vous avez des filières qui
sont
exclusivement
dédiés à certains usages
donc on va prendre par exemple antimoine
80% de l'antimoine c'est les
retardateurs de flamme c'est ce qu'on
met pour éviter que l'électro magnétique
ans assure chauffe ça explose ou qu'il y
ait des trucs l'épreuve avec les
incendies etc
par exemple 80 ou 70 ou
80% de l'indium en l'occurrence c'est
les les écrans à états indiens oxyde
d'étain indium donc c'est les écrans qui
sont tactiles qui vous permette du coup
de créer des impulsions électriques avec
le déplacement du doigt le gallium par
exemple le gallium 80% du gallium c'est
de l'arséniure de gallium qui est
utilisé dans les circuits intégrés et
qui a pu certes un avantage par rapport
aux la silicium et c'est donc ces
secteurs là ce sont des secteurs qui
sont très polarisée et je vous dirai en
fait que en général
ce sont des filières qui sont conscients
ce qu'on appelle les métaux de
spécialité c'est à dire pas les métaux
de base ou les métaux précieux qu'on
connaît assez bien mais des métaux de
spécialités l'arsenic l'antimoine le
germanium le gallium et axel le tantale
quand vous avez des filières comme le
cuivre vous avez des filières avec
beaucoup de concurrence ça change la
donne en fait c'est à dire que je vais
vous donner un exemple on parlait du
cuivre un marché avec le véhicule
électrique surtout si on fait une écrite
avec 80 kilos à chaque fois ça va
compliquer sans compter les fameuses
bornes de recharge à 100 kg et tout le
reste mais je vais vous donner un
exemple le nickel parce qu'on en parle
beaucoup on dit voilà une batterie au
nickel manganèse cobalt le premier terme
c'est michael je le disais tout à
l'heure sur une batterie tigo et on est
à onze on est à 34 kg de nickel parce
que le cobalt au stylo de manganèse très
bien et en fait on ne dit rien et dans
le monde deux en nickel vous rendez
compte pour les véhicules électriques
pour l'électrification vers
l'électrification des véhicules et ils
savent à être un énorme poste en 2020 70
% du nom qu'elle
sait les aciers inoxydables
et ça a toujours été le nickel les
aciers inoxydables c'est connu pour ça
vous savez l'expression nickel chrome là
c'est les aciers ferronickel ou
ferronickel cros
les batteries c'est 8%
si on envisage des parcs véhicules
électriques tels que c'est aujourd'hui
annoncé avec du 100 % électrique où il
faut que tous les quatre matins en
balance 34 pour 34 kg 10 dans la
batterie pascal chaumeil en eire et
firent n'a pas que dans la batterie met
donc en l'occurrence le gros postes
effectivement c'est le poste des
batteries ah bah ça va être compliqué on
pourra pas satisfaire tout le monde donc
vous avez
acculé riches bah on sait alors à savoir
en fait comment ça va se passer parce
que je sais par an toujours du prix
bon là ça va être alors quelles vont
être les dynamiques moi je suis pas
nostradamus je vous avouerai mais il va
y avoir forcément des phénomènes
concurrentiel que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure de tensions d'approvisionnement
ou de tensions politiques voire
géopolitique qui vont nécessairement
intervenir qui entre guillemets le plus
fort entre lobby des véhicules
électriques et le lobby des aciers
inoxydables je ne saurais pas répondre à
cette question je ne vais pas me je vais
pas me lancer par contre en fait ce qui
est sûr c'est que
aujourd'hui il va y avoir des arbitrages
à faire entre certains usages parce que
on pour les ariz notre attention sur
certain âge
je me permets de revenir à ce titre là
sur le véhicule électrique vous parce
que en fait quand on disait alors non
seulement c'est beaucoup plus émetteurs
ont quantifie pas un certain nombre de
choses mais enfin faut s'imaginer des
ordres de grandeur en cause je prends un
autre métal on change pensais pas le
nickel et le cobalt on prend le cobalt
d'après une publication dans géologue de
mars 2020
sur le véhicule électrique le simple a
donc c'est une publication de mars 2020
le simple fait
de passer au tout électrique donc le si
vous voulez le surplus l'udc est
nécessaire en cobalt 1 le surplus qu'est
nécessaires pour répondre à un
une alimentation vain une transformation
du parc électrique du parc automobile en
100% électrique
rien que ce surplus la indépendamment
d'une éventuelle croissance sur les
autres secteurs qui est ont besoin de
cobayes consentants juste pour le parc
100% électrique
c'était une fin du cobalt disponible en
tombée en 2050 on sera tous vos
questions à internet est il d'ailleurs
qui
résonne avec ce que ce que vous avez dit
est il possible d'extraire durablement
entre parenthèses sur plusieurs siècles
tous les métaux nécessaires à la
population humaine actuelle
[Rires]
mais l'acteur ben men actuelle déjà
c'est extrêmement compliqué et alors
humaine actuelle avec ses pronostics à
venir non c'est non
question internet quelles perspectives
pour le lithium en france mon pain de
plus en plus de l'exploitation durable
était envisageable
alors je ne suis pas une experte denis
tienne moi je préfère le dire dès le
départ
moi je j'ai vu donc là je ne parle pas
au nom de six textes je parle au nom de
moi
j'ai tout le font au nom d'horreur
stefan voilà j'ai vu un certain nombre
de projets notamment en termes de
géothermie c'est à dire de valorisation
d'eau
géothermique dans le canton pour
extraire un pourcentage or certes faible
mais in fine est intéressant en termes
de lithium je pense que ça peut être
intéressant malheureusement je n'ai pas
pu développer les enjeux techniques y
sont associés dont je me rends pas
compte de ce que ça représente mais
c'est ce genre de méthode que je trouve
assez intéressante sous réserve qu'ils
aient déjà un usage en fait de ces eaux
géothermale autant en profiter pour
récupérer des choses
maximisez autant que possible bien
naturellement le recyclage d'autant
qu'aujourd'hui c'était pas vrai il ya
quelques années mais aujourd'hui le
marché du lithium se polarise sur le le
milieu de la batterie il ya quelques
années quand je donnais des formations
je disais aujourd'hui le plus gros du
lithium c'est la vitrocéramique ses 35%
des usages mondiaux puisqu'il ya
quelques années pied aujourd'hui voyez
où on en est les rapports sont inversés
les batteries deviennent de devenir
majoritaires en termes de demande de
lithium donc il ya ces enjeux
intéressant
la question du lithium que vous posez en
disant est ce que l'on peut faire une
mine durable
je pense que ce que j'expliquais en
introduction je pense qu'il faut
vraiment l'avoir en tête pour se rendre
compte en fait de certaines limites
intrinsèques dans la façon dont on peut
exploiter une mine à partir du moment où
vous le travailler avec des quantités
importantes on parle de millions de
tonnes de matériaux en souterrain alors
qu'il ya de l'eau qu'il faut pomper qui
a plein de métaux et métalloïdes plupart
sont toxiques c'est ça la mine ça va
bien se passer ce qu'on peut faire c'est
minimiser au maximum
le problème c'est que pour minimiser
encore faut-il avoir des technologies
qui permettent de minimiser et force est
constater que sont dans ce domaine n'en
déplaise à beaucoup qui prétendent qu'il
y a énormément d'alternative et de
meilleures pratiques alors on n'est pas
du tout au même niveau que d'autres
secteurs industriels
donc la question du lithium je pense
qu'ils auraient notamment fins et
notamment les projets géothermiques que
j'aurais trouvé intéressant mais je n'ai
pas pu les approfondir
je vais attraper doute question internet
puissent entrer il faut des blagues
fusent et si vous voulez me raconter une
blague non surtout pas non
comment proposez-vous de réintégrer le
prix des externalités dont les prix
assez une superbe questions merci
beaucoup de la reposer
et bien comment on pourrait commencer
s'est déjà
essayé de regarder en moyenne en fin de
de quantifier ou de modéliser des
impacts moyens contenu des teneurs en
éléments métalliques qu'on s'attend ou
qu'on pense avoir et des tonnages faire
typiquement on peut se dire globalement
sur une mine de tant de millions tonnes
je m'attends à voir tant de millions de
tonnes de déchets en fonction des
teneurs moyennes et c est comment on
pourrait réintégrer des externalités il
y aurait déjà une première façon de
faire c'est en dessous d'une certaine
teneur on n'exploite pas
parce que cette teneur la plus de sens
le plus rapide mais j'ai pas dit qu'il
fallait pas en parallèle diminuer les
quantités de métaux que nous allions
consommer tout à fait que vous avez
raison de le préciser moi ce que je dis
déjà c'est s'agissant de l'intégration
des externalités le premier levier c'est
déjà de dire il ya une teneur en dessous
laquelle on peut plus aller alors dans
les faits il ya une teneur sous laquelle
on ne peut plus aller je me permets
juste cette parenthèse c'est
en fait le métal donc comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure plus les toners diminue
enfin plus le temps avance plus les
toners diminue c'est un sujet qui fait
consensus chez tout le monde j'ai envie
d'en parler c'est un sujet qui fait
consensus la diminution progressive des
teneur des gisements mondiaux et la
raréfaction des gisements facilement
exploitables un sujet qui fait consensus
ça fait du bien aux gens parlent avec
enthousiasme et donc du coup
il ya des gens qui depuis des gens
extrêmement connue pour ce qu'ils voient
comme mode comme northgate et ac comme
nos rêves qui depuis est pour 15 ans en
fait montre que plus les teneurs diminue
plus la quantité d'énergie augmente plus
la quantité d'eau augmente de façon
exponentielle
comme la production vous et et c'est ça
le parallèle parallèle est bon c'est
vraiment exponentielle donc
l'une des façons justement de de sport
de prévoir ça c'est de dire on sait déjà
alors bien sûr qu'on n'y a pas un
chiffrage précis mais on peut déjà
commencer à modéliser des prédictions en
termes de quantité d'eau supplémentaires
ou encore termes de quantité d'impact
supplémentaires ou en termes de etc et
savent déjà on pourrait déjà l'imputé en
disant bas compte tenu des pronostics
que l'on peut faire avec des cours -
découpe de tendance qu'il ya un moment
défini un point au delà duquel on n'a
pas ce serait dès lors vous aurez tous
et je vous dis la science et la
technologie va nous sauver on va moins
consommer d'où on va avoir plus de
rendement parce que cette technologie va
la trouver
il faut nous laisser faire des trous
parce que si on va pas la trouver il
s'arrête de votre faute vous vous rendez
pas compte ça va être de ma faute
beaucoup de choses sur mes épaules je
suis consciente donc j'ai fini et je
vous réponds sur les techniques c'est
promis donc donc la premier moyen
d'aller quantifier se dire qu'il ya déjà
des externalités qu'on assume pas et
notamment pour ceux qui s'intéressent à
un chercheur qui s'appelle bout de lande
qui a fait un très bon travail là dessus
qu'ils travaillent en fait sur le
responsible mining et autres et en fait
qui explique ces intrus travaux de 2012
etc explique en fait que ya des
frontières ou des limites qu'on devra
imposer notamment dans les zones de
bassins versants n'y va pas dans les
zones qui sont naturels protégés on n'y
va pas etc etc faut déjà se mettre des
limites pour moi le premier niveau de la
prise en compte des externalités c'est
définir ce qu'on accepte et ce qu'on
n'accepte pas et tout ce qu'on accepte
pas on n'y va pas et ça va forcément
influé bas effectivement sur les toners
et sur les zones ont exploité autre
façon du coup d'aborder les externalités
et ben c'est le prix c'est à dire que et
toute cette question prix c'est-à-dire
que quand vous regardez par exemple on
va prendre tiens on va prendre cet
exemple là je trouve qu'il est chouette
donc or il ya énormément de mines d'or
dans le monde lors et même s'il ya très
peu de production finale c'est que trois
à quatre mille tonnes par ans et il ya
beaucoup d'or donc on cyanure l'or et on
a des problèmes dans les bassins ou des
normands prennent de fuite des flux en
deux grands bassins de grands parcs à
résidus contiennent des au cyanure et et
on a des soucis tout eu des fuites
annoncé des fuites non d'un an quand
vous avez un trouble dans un
énoncé des fuites ci a pas d'autre mot
j'en ai vu plat des fuites j'en ai vu
plein plein plein et il y en a pleins
partout autour des digues etc des fuites
et ya pas de toi moi si vous voulez je
peux faire très attention à ce que je
dis
je peux pondérée des flics et des pluies
n'ont pas des écoulements donc tout ça
pour dire que on a dit il ya un problème
parce que on peut pas se permettre on a
eu pas mal d'accidents de rejeter dans
des eaux qui sont bas à la surface ont
fait un des au cyanure et donc on a dit
on va faire ce qu'on appelle de la
destruction de signe en tout le monde
applaudit à demain en disant ça c'est
super qu'ils utilisent pour la
destruction de seniors moi je me suis
intéressé à aux industries minières et
quelle qualité lors la plainte
technologie de destruction de seniors
extraits et en plus c'est un peu humble
dire ce que je crois que je l'aï entendu
dans mes cours à l'époque et j'aurais dû
m'en souvenir en fait la discussion de
seniors ce pack destruction de cyanure
du tout c'est une dégradation du cyanure
dont la forme libre du cyanure ans yann
hat et antisociales at&t refaisons mais
l'oxygène ça fait des produits
dégradation sa fédé scianna td tiatia
n'a que peu importe sauf que c'est
sienna tessiture celles ci continuent à
poser sévèrement problème à
l'environnement oui c'est plus du sud
mais c'est plus du cyanure donc on peut
parler de destruction du cyanure
comprenez les jours et joue soft ou le
cyanure sait pas très bien si vous leur
parlez c'est de sa dette
tout de suite ça fait alors c'est vrai
que la toxicité moindre 1 est en train
scianna t1 cyanure libre la différence
est clair mais par contre le problème
c'est qu'on les rejets dans
l'environnement et qu'il faudrait total
annoncé moins toxiques ce qu'on dit
c'est juste que c'est moins toxiques
mais ça veut pas dire du coup que
d'enclencher des grandes quantités ne va
poser aucun problème environnemental
soit parce que c'est moins toxique que
c'est pas toxique c'est juste moins
toxiques
donc ça c'est un premier enjeu est donc
du coup je me suis moi je vais
m'intéresser à une technique et
prometteuse qui est la question du
recyclage
recyclage de cyanure on change un peu de
spect par rapport aux cycles âge
métalliques c'est à dire que du coup on
va récupérer le cyanure pour en fait
justement éviter qu'il y en ait trop qui
partent et effectivement quand ça
s'oxyde pas de générer trop de cionet et
nationales le nombre de sites mini qui
procède à cette technique qui est
pourtant hyper intéressante ça tient sur
les doigts d'une à demain
il ya bien plus qu'une à demain deux
doigts de sites d'or dans le monde donc
si vous voulez il ya des enjeux que ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que la
raison aujourd'hui qui est pour en avoir
ensuite parlé en plus avec des amis à
moi qui travaille dans l'industrie
minérale des représentants du secteur de
l'industrie minérale j'entends tout à
fait les enjeux économiques y sont
associés à une telle usine de traitement
j'entends tout à fait les difficultés
aujourd'hui qu'on à a fui économiquement
parlant à ne pas gérer les déchets
autrement que sous forme de boues déposé
derrière des barrages dans des dykes qui
se trouve dans une montagne je comprends
les difficultés économiques là je peux
les comprendre théoriquement là où je ne
les comprends pas pratiquement c'est que
je sais que parmi tous les consommateurs
eh bien ils n'auraient certainement
qu'il serait prêt à payer à payer un
prix juste comme ils l'ont fait dans
d'autres secteurs industriels et dans
d'autres secteurs de production ils sont
déjà prêts à payer un prix plus juste
parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'est pas normal
qu'un téléphone coûte 100 de son mal
même mille euros c'est rien pour un
téléphone ce n'est absolument rien
compte tenu des externalités que la mine
fait peser du point de vue humain du
point de vue social du point de vue
environnemental
donc ce qui est important pour moi c'est
de dire il faut reconstruire un modèle
où on ne on ne fait pas l'apologie d'un
modèle où on est toujours un rapiécé les
bouts de ficelle pour pouvoir avoir une
mine la moins chère possible amis
l'apologie du coût de production plus
faibles possibles dans une industrie qui
est intrinsèquement aussi problématique
est dangereux moi j'ai des rendements à
fournir
chez les romains fournir un des
actionnaires
ses romans des randos mais à des
rendements pardon ah oui
d'ailleurs le secteur minier est l'un
des seuls secteurs du primaire auquel on
implique des taux de rendements aussi
élevés que ceux du tertiaire montagne
dans l'état 18% de retour sur
investissement il fit magnifique non
mais c'est pas raisonnable de
magnifiques vues % c'est une industrie
c'est une infirme et je suis désolé
d'être en désaccord apparemment
simplement apparent avec vous mais
d'être en désaccord mais moi je peux pas
concevoir je ne peux pas humainement
concevoir qu'on soit prêt pour des
raisons économiques à faire des choix
qui sont aussi désastreux pour mais
c'est pas c'est ce que je vais vous dire
en fait c'est que souvent j'en parle
avec des gens là dedans mais vous rendre
enfin vous rendez pas compte des impacts
on est pote avec des chèvres
j'en parle avec des personnes qui ne
sont pas du tout des secteurs et je leur
parle des problèmes environnementaux et
pee wee b bons aurore c'est bon on
connaît le sujet on sait que c'est grave
mais bon finito jti qu'elles sont
mais en fait
les impacts il faut vraiment avoir en
tête que les impacts sont extrêmement
différents et bien plus grave quand je
vous parle de pollution moi je vous
parle de kilomètres je te prends ton
temps les petits jours m 15 % c'était
mieux on continue comme ça les 18% et
donc ce que je te fais si vous voulez le
paradoxe qu'il ya dedans c'est de dire
27 industrie elle va nécessairement
poser problème de par la nature que j'ai
décrite précédemment donc le seul moyen
de s'en tirer à bon compte pas trop mal
c'est minimiser au maximum les impacts
pour ce faire pour minimiser au maximum
les impacts on dispose aujourd'hui de
technologies qui sont extrêmement
coûteuses
je discutais ya pas si longtemps
justement toujours les cyanure ce qu'on
a fait une étude des télés soit question
de la cyanuration
cette année avec six textes je discutais
avec deux experts canadiens des cyanures
qu'ils disent est nommé au rang de
cardinaux dans la tête raison pour
laquelle on utilise le cyanure ce
qu'aujourd'hui au prix à la tonne s'y
perd l'avantagé on est à 4 dollars la
tonne qui veut qu'on fasse de mieux
qu'un thiosulfate aujourd'hui on a 25
dollars la tonne arrête de te prendre la
tête c'est bon pour elle passe à autre
chose passe à autre chose jours
donc du coup
j'ai déjà il faut augmenter ça va coûter
cher mais il va falloir changer des
techniques il va faire changer des
façons de faire changer des habitudes et
en particulier sur un des points noirs
de l'industrie qu'est la gestion des
déchets miniers qui soit à l'étape de
l'exploitation à l'étape du déchet il
faut déjà commencer par ça gérer les
effluents gérer les déchets et on met
beaucoup d'argent de denrées quel que
soit le prix il faut mettre le prix là
dedans si en contrepartie de ce la fin
en corollaire excusez-moi de cela et
bien on a un taux ou un coût de
production qui augmente il chargea de
s'arranger pour vendre leur production à
des taux plus attractifs du moins des
prix plus attractif plus mon problème
à un moment donné et si on n'arrive à
expliquer aux gens qu'on n'a pas
aujourd'hui à accepter un certain nombre
de dégâts majeurs que ce soit les des
versements volontaires que ce soit les
techniques extrêmement invasive aux
autres et il y en a tellement raconté
sur les techniques invasives qu'il
faudrait interdire il faut absolument
que nous on soit en capacité de dire il
ya un certain nombre de techniques qui
doivent absolument être bannie il ya des
techniques qui doivent être mises en
oeuvre ça va coûter de l'argent il faut
le faire et en parallèle il faut
informer les gens pour que les gens
disent de la même façon que dans
d'autres secteurs d'activité je suis
prêt à faire d'autres choix parce que ça
répond à mes besoins parce que ça répond
en monétique je ferai pareil avec la bim
et les métaux alors une question très
intéressante sur notre chat je connais
déjà la réponse pour cela pousse
où trouver le site de six textes le site
internet vous avez des réseaux sociaux
ainsi que quelque chose alors le site
internet de six textes et si ce texte
point org ww pour ainsi ce texte pour un
orgue
voilà alors par contre nous n'avons
aucun réseau social alors quasiment pas
moi je n'ai pas de réseau social à titre
personnel j'utilise simplement mon
compte linkedin pour informer de
certaines de certains événements de
certaines publications mais qui sont
uniquement liés à de la publication
et assistex n'avons pas de réseau social
pourquoi
parce que pour nous il ya deux choses la
première chose c'est que le temps des
réseaux sociaux
n'est clairement pas le temps de six
textes si ce texte travail pendant des
heures on va chercher ce qui fait
consensus donc on va chercher plusieurs
sources on va les corréler on va essayer
de
d'avoir le maximum de sources
concordantes
et le plus grand nombre possible avant
de se faire une opinion et ensuite de
détailler un argumentaire c'est le
domaine du temps l'on s'est pas
véritablement le domaine des réseaux
sociaux que souvent je suis par exemple
baassiste et que ce n'est pas très à
l'aise avec des interventions où on est
sur des durées courtes parce que je vais
mettre énormément nuance pense que vous
l'avez compris ce soir tu vas dans une
critique de la mine j'ai pas du tout
dans une critique absolue à la bim sa
maman je suis j'essaye de avec six
textes on essaye en fait de pouvoir en
comprendre toute la complexité dira dans
tout ce bazar là on peut agir en sur sa
priorité et ça il faut arrêter on va
déjà commencer à travailler là-dessus et
c'est vraiment une approche par priorité
et si vous voulez par ce qui est
acceptable est pas acceptable c'est ça
notre approche autre chose si cette expo
nunes des numérisations pas seulement
une sobriété numérique qui ne suffit pas
forcément c'est à dire en fait on
souhaite faire marche arrière sur le
numérique donc c'est pas une sobriété
c'est une marche arrière aux coiffures
vous ce petit côté amish
[Rires]
ça change tout à fait
et en fait on prône une des
numérisations et donc la logique c'est
que si vous êtes quoi mais vous pouvez
difficilement tous les quatre matins
publié trois phrases et une image sur un
asocial et parallèlement dire les métaux
du numérique ça va pas du tout non c'est
pas possible vous êtes obligés et moi je
trouve ça très bien aussi parce que
en fait le fait d'être déconnecté de
certaines actualités qui sont traités
par les réseaux ça nous permet aussi
voyez de pas avoir de sentir happés par
des injonctions qui sont souvent liées
au temps médiatique par exemple
ça arrive à six textes on dirait qu on
est sollicité tous les jours pour des
interviews pour des expertises pour des
analyses de documents pour des
rencontres avec des personnes jeunes
loups qui ar ça peut être toutes sortes
de presse
avait alors déjà on travaille pas pour
toutes les presses comme on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps on donne priorité à la
presse indépendante et à la presse
publique qu'elle soit audiovisuel ou
écrites
et puis ensuite du coup comme vous le
disait on sera pas forcément à l'aise
avec ba une question du style oui mais
enfin bon si on n'est pas pour lamine ba
on n'est pas pour le progrès
oui libye faute oui j'ai le pp phoque ce
qui est absolument pas une façon de rire
de vos bébés phoques sachez-le parce que
j
notation milliers en antarctique
voilà les c'est comme les fonds marins
revenons à la question
contre le progrès oui voilà vous êtes
contre le projet est donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle aussi c'est la
raison pour laquelle on ne voit pas
beaucoup vous poussez deux raisons la
cire comptera pas beaucoup dans des
médias instantanée ou avec une forme
d'immédiateté où on peut pas développer
notre propos comme là je le fais ce soir
pour expliquer et mettre toute la nuance
et puis aussi parce que il ya des mois
on vous dit enfin je vous donne un je
caricature mais c'est important que les
gens comprennent aussi pourquoi on n'est
pas très présent on veut dire il ya été
le sujet alors il ya sujets atteints à
l'open code minier nan nan un tel sujet
talent ordonnance qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
dans ces cas là je regarde fermement la
personne je n'ai aucune mais alors pas
la moindre et je crois pas travailler
sur la lune vous devriez le savoir c'est
quand même incroyable chimie nantes et
j'en ai pas la moindre idée mais en fait
si le sujet est d'importance dans on va
l'étudier mais ça va nous prendre du
temps parce qu'on va consulter beaucoup
de gens on va s'interroger sur des yeux
qui sont pas forcément nos coeurs de
métier je suis pas juriste par exemple
de formation et le temps que je fasse à
l'actualité aura switcher sur un autre
sujet pour ça qu'on a créé cette chaîne
youtube en dehors du temps médiatique et
en dehors du simple et court ce qu'on
trouve que c'est le passeport pour le
slogan idéologique pur et c'est pas
notre
jeu comprend peut-être je fais juste un
commentaire en direct à vorace qui en
train de nous appeler pour dire que
c'est le bordel dans le tchat au niveau
des discussions et on va on va se lâcher
merci pour nous faire remonter
l'information il peut parler de
recyclage voulez parler de recyclage ou
bien sûr et du coup ça je vais vous
proposer un lien entre la question là
des numérisations j'évoquais
précédemment et la question du recyclage
comme ça on va rester sur cette
transition
sauver jean moulin
[Rires]
donc on parlait là des numérisations
alors je vais vous raconter d'abord une
toute petite histoire c'est juste pour
poser des jalons qui après on passe à la
suite la petite histoire en fait c'est
que donc si vous avez le tableau de
mendeleïev en tête
à peu près vous avez toujours
j'adore ce tableau il est merveilleux
donc dans ce tableau vous avez sept
métaux ferreux qui sont globalement les
métaux qu'on va dire les métaux des
aciers on connaît assez bien le faire on
sert connaît assez bien le manganèse
donc c'est fer manganèse nickel chrome
les aciers inoxydables et puis ensuite
du coup il ya le niobium le vanadium et
le molybdène ensuite ça c'est les métaux
ferreux et ensuite vous avez le monde
des métaux non ferreux le monde donc là
je me base sur la catégorisation qui a
été proposé par le programme des nations
unies pour l'environnement en 2011 en
lien avec les travaux l'international
ressources planète pour préciser le
cadre de cette catégorie que je vais
vous proposer ici ensuite du coup vous
avez les métaux non ferreux les métaux
qu'on connaît aussi le cuivre le zinc
ils sont au nombre de huit le cuivre le
zinc le plomb l'aluminium l'étain le
titane ensuite vous avez les métaux
précieux qu'on connaît assez bien
finalement l'or l'argent le platine le
palladium et puis a donc quatre petits
frères qui vont avec qui son des
platines rilos même iridium le ruthénium
le rhodium bon et après vous en avez 37
qui vous manquent dans le tableau de
mendeleïev là dans les métaux et la
source à très intéressant parce que le
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement les appelle c'est tous
ces métaux là les appelle les métaux les
speciality metals les métaux de
spécialités
dedans vous avez alors des noms qu'on
connaît dès que nous on connaît moins
bien où vous avez l'antimoine le
germanium le gallium le tantale et le
tungstène le béryllium vous avez tous
les trois
et c'est assez intéressant je trouve de
les appeler les métaux de spécialité
parce que comme je le mentionnais
précédemment sur l'indium sur le gars du
gallium ou autre il y avait
effectivement une spécificité qui est
assez remarquable pour la plupart de ces
métaux c'est qu'ils servent souvent un
certain usage ça peut être les capteurs
ça peut être voilà les supraconducteurs
ça peut être voilà toutes sortes de
choses et ce qui est intéressant en fait
c'est que les technologies du numérique
elles ont une spécificité par rapport à
tous les autres secteurs industriels qui
utilisent des métaux dont on a parlé
précédemment c'est qu'en fait elles sont
assez vorace de ces méthodes spécialité
dans un smartphone par exemple au moyen
d'après une étude que si ce texte a
conduit en 2016 2017 il ya s'il y avait
50 de substances différentes dans un
téléphone portable
52 substance on n'est pas loin d'avoir
fini de remplir les cases du tableau de
mendeleïev
donc on a fait cette étude sur le long
cours pour essayer de comprendre quelles
étaient les métaux et qui servait à quoi
et on s'est rendu compte que ma
effectivement vous trouvez un certain
nombre d'éléments tels que les terreur
etc etc oui d'ailleurs je peux ouvrir
une parenthèse si vous le permettez sur
les terres rares gien
sur les terres rares en fait les terreur
ne sont pas rares je sais que c'est
aberrant dit comme ça ce com jeudi quand
le dîner stériles miniers ne sont pas
stériles dit mais vous concerne vous
choisissez votre vocabulaire dans
secteur minier pour dire exactement l
inverse de la réalité bon les terreur ne
sont pas rares elles sont même au plus
voir autant ou plus abondante que les
métaux de base qu'on connaît en fait
donc les terrasses et les lanthanides
plus de deux métaux le scandium et
l'yttrium et de nom on les appelle
l'état à ce que c'est un groupe de
métaux qui ont des propriétés proches
peu importe pour rappel et ses terres
rares là en fait elles ne sont
absolument pas rares et il ya un énorme
engouement sur la question des terrains
talent mais c'est d'aimer ton assez en
plus il ya eu des problèmes avec la
chine qu'à bloquer les
approvisionnements ça a créé des
problèmes d'impression et c'est à une
espèce de polarisation du discours
autour des terrasses non plus à quinton
avec un nom pareil forcément que ça fait
fantasmer alors on va rappeler les
choses 1 les terres rares c'est un
groupe de 15 plus de vingt quinze
montagny plus de métaux sépare du tout
on sait aussi abondant que les métaux de
base on en produit 240 mille tonnes
d'oxydés de terres rares par ans à ces
chiffres de 2020 pour mémoire on produit
trois à quatre mille tonnes d'or par an
on produit 240 mille tonnes d'oxydé de
tara et c'est aussi des métaux justement
de spécialité notamment regard de leurs
propriétés magnétiques notamment
luminophores ce qu'ils sont deux grandes
propriétés
c'est caractéristique est connue de
cette famille de métaux je ferme la
parenthèse donc ce dont on s'est rendu
compte en fait c'est que à la croissance
métallique que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est à dire on consomme en quantité de
plus en plus de métaux s'ajoute une
nouvelle une autre tendance qui est la
diversification c'est à dire qu'on a des
métaux qui sont on a des dispositifs qui
ont une de plus en plus de métaux
différents à l'intérieur pour voter à 52
ans moyenne sur un smartphone c'est vous
dire quoi son monte à 71 sur un véhicule
électrique à payer tout le tableau de
mendeleïev là il ya plus rien il ment
plus que les gaz rares et les actinides
c'est à dire en gros la famille de
l'uranium quoi mais ils n'ont plus
personne si elliott et le radium excusez
moi voilà donc bref donc je ferme la
parenthèse sur cette divers et cette
diversification mais telle qu'elle est
extrêmement importante parce que etc
savent allier si ça va jouer sur le
recyclage en fait c'est que le fait que
l'on associe de grandes quantités de
métaux va nécessairement sein de grandes
quantités certes est un problème mais
des quantités
diverses diversifié si vous voulez et à
des échelles fine d'un nécessairement
engendrer et bien des difficultés de
recyclage dire c'est pas la même que de
voir recycler un appareil de cette
taille là à 50 de métaux que de recycler
du câble électrique qui alimente un
bâtiment par exemple y compris du petit
mont fond pour aller récupérer d'autres
métallique jackson vous avez déjà vu des
encres métalliques notamment en dopage
sur les boîtiers les angles métallique
monique elle même avec des petites mains
ça marche pas oui non ça marche les
petits-enfants
donc ce soit effectivement dans le
domaine des encres métalliques ça peut
être les dopages aussi c'est à dire
qu'on prend une matrice et qu'on met à
l'intérieur des atomes de quelque chose
pour leur conférer pour leur donner des
propriétés spécifiques et vous avez 1 2
le troisième monde merveilleux des
alliages complexe j'ouvre une parenthèse
ça fait 3 heures huit camps durée non
est ce que vous voulez prendre le record
de la chaîne
une question internet qui dit quid du
graphène mes graphes et ne s'est pas
votre secteur d'activité non enfin celle
du carbone spécifique mais je connais
beaucoup moins je sais que c'est utilisé
en substitution tout à fait donc je ne
poserai pas les questions sur le
graphène parce que madame est ingénieur
géologue spécialisés
oui c'est ça d'exploitation qu'est ce
qui vous arrive à la fin de notre
notre interview
vous savez trois livres à nous
conseiller oui
elle a promis il faut vraiment vraiment
lire et il faut surtout le relire
maintenant c'est germinal de zola fou le
relire maintenant faut le relire
aujourd'hui
parce qu'à bien des égards en fait il ya
beaucoup d'enseignements de zola que
visiblement pour on aurait pu apprendre
à la lecture de zola que visiblement n'a
pas appris on n'a pas eu le temps de
développer ce soir en fait notamment sur
la question des nouvelles technologies
de tout ce que les nouvelles techniques
cettex a réalisé une étude très
détaillée qui sont le site internet là
dessus qu'ils démontrent en fait à quel
point les techniques et technologies
minières sont extrêmement immersif je
trouve que c'est intéressant et le
germinal de se rappeler ça il ya un
autre livre qui moi m'a beaucoup marqué
ça s'appelle les minerais du sang de
christophe boltanski alors c'est un
focus une enquête sur la filière de
l'état
certes l'exploitation initial c'est une
exploitation à petite échelle on est
habillé en république démocratique du
congo mais par contre cette enquête elle
est extrêmement intéressant pour
comprendre l'intégralité du
fonctionnement de d'une filière de a à z
fait ce qui est extraordinaire dans ce
livre c'est que c'est la première
enquête pour moi qui existe qui part de
la mine et qui va jusqu'aux produits
finis en passant par les métallurgistes
et c'est
le troisième livre c'est certainement
j'ai longtemps hésité en disant qu est
ce que je pourrais conseiller comme
lecture peut-être la fin de la
mégamachine de fabienne scheidel qui est
un ouvrage qui a été traduit en 2020 qui
travaille notamment sur les qui
s'intéresse notamment même si c'est pas
mon mon coeur de métier mais ça nous
apprend énormément de chose justement
sur les modèles les systèmes les modèles
de domination aussi et là
voilà je trouve que c'est assez
intéressant de replacer cette question
de systématisme de systèmes isme et de
modèles de modèle politique de modèles
économiques et de les replacer par
rapport à
ces matières premières minérales qui
constitue l'adn justement de notre
modèle de développement vous avez un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissables qui va rester sur ces
réseaux gaver de béton
je le crois sincèrement parce que j'ai
me suis longtemps posé la question il
faut pas avoir peur il faut oser il faut
avoir faut pas avoir peur de la critique
faut pas avoir peur de travailler ces
sujets
mais il faut y aller il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce sujet
et dans d'autres et on n'est pas moins
légitime parce qu'on est plus jeunes
aux femmes tout à fait donc je pense que
moi si j'avais un conseil à donner aux
jeunes aujourd'hui c'est le lundi oser
allez-y confrontez vous aussi à vos
pairs on a une vision notamment dans les
expertises ont la science où il ya des
pères qui sont sa chambre puis les
nouveaux venus qui n'y connaissent rien
je pense qu'on a beaucoup de choses à
apprendre les uns des autres oser
allez-y foncez
j'avais des questions à temps
il y avait des questions concernant les
plantes et champignons pour le recyclage
des métaux et ainsi de suite
ah oui notamment la phytostabilisation
et la phytoremédiation on en reparlera
la prochaine vous y revenir nous voir
d'accord or stefan merci
[Musique]
com